Huh?
The best round of applause I've ever gotten in my life.
You guys know,
not Jordan Peterson,
right?
I know he jacked the beard and now everybody's getting has been very nimble.
Wow.
This is incredibly exciting.
This is the beginning of the 12 rules tour and you guys are out here to discuss
ideas.
Giving yourselves around it.
Whoa.
Really awesome.
I mean,
we're kicking this thing off.
I'm joining Jordan on the tour.
I mean,
really look around for a second.
Like the world is upside down and you guys are here because you want some
answers that that is incredible.
I actually
right one prisons with me.
That's what I like.
I liked the idea that,
what about you guys?
No,
no,
I agree with that.
You agree with that?
Ladies and gentlemen,
you preempted a joke.
I was going to do in two minutes,
but I think that works.
Yeah.
Jordan wanted Kathy to open,
but uh,
so I just had dinner with Jordan.
He's incredibly excited for this and kicking this thing off at the beacon,
this incredible place.
Uh,
everybody that was there,
all the agents were there.
The,
the book be boy,
they're the managers.
Everybody.
Everyone had steak.
Uh,
Jordan had lobster.
Yeah,
he actually made eat the lobster.
He just beat it relentlessly.
Yes.
With a mallet over and over.
Who's your daddy?
Israeli.
It's,
I can see how many of you guys saw my,
uh,
my sit down with,
with Dr. Peterson.
And eventually,
you know,
it's funny because Jordan's got this,
this thing about the lobsters of course,
that you guys all know about.
Ben Is an Orthodox Jew.
So literally for like an hour in the green room,
Ben was like,
could you just switch it to fulfill the vision plan?
Okay.
Now I know how many Jews are in the crowd.
Very good.
Z.
How many of you self identify as lobsters by the way?
It's very important.
Oh,
we got a lobster claw look at,
I was walking around with stuff.
Lots of these people.
Are we making a difference?
You see my point
there really is very,
something amazing happening here.
I,
I love it.
You know,
it's funny,
I actually,
and I think probably similar to many of you guys,
I didn't know who Jordan was until about a year and a half ago and he was last
October actually,
right?
And suddenly,
I'm sure for some of you guys that were doing it,
people started tweeting at me,
you know,
you gotta talk to,
this is Jordan Peterson guy up in Toronto.
You gotta talk to this guy.
And we had him on my show and it was,
we were building out our studio.
So we did a Google hangout and the connection wasn't great because we didn't
have great internet yet.
And I'm,
I'm doing this Google hangout with this guy.
And I really was just learning about him as I was talking to him.
And here's this guy crying over Pinocchio.
Sure.
Lion King.
That makes sense to me.
A little mermaid seeing I was hysterical,
but crying over Pinocchio.
Well,
what is going on here?
What is this?
What is this thing?
And I got to tell you guys had,
in the last year,
I have truly learned what this thing is,
this,
this guy is at the forefront.
I think of what all the right ideas are right there.
There are a lot of bad ideas out there.
Right.
Can plug good ideas.
And that's right.
Where's the,
where's the girl that I was tweeting with before?
By the way,
I had that you deleted the tweet.
Where are you?
Very,
Yo.
What up her clothing?
She made a mistake with Twitter and then I tweeted her and she deleted it and
she's going through a line.
Oh yeah.
It goes down here.
I'll go back to China.
If anyone should be building a wall.
It's Canada and frankly,
yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
The Canadians are down or that,
uh,
yeah,
like Trudeau could build anything
with Jordan.
He started,
you know,
there was this whole issue about the pronouns,
right?
That Jordan basically said,
I am a free man of my own free will and free mind and the government cannot tell
me what pronouns to use.
That doesn't mean I dislike.
Ooh,
yeah,
you got it.
You fully realized that this is a live show.
I like that.
No tape delay.
Your applaud.
Go crazy.
You can scream whatever you want to do.
Thank you,
sir.
Thank you very much.
My parents are here.
This is this.
What'd I tell your mom?
Good night.
You too.
Look,
it's going to work out
okay.
But really old Jordan wanted to do is the exact same thing that any of us want
to do,
which is exercise our mind.
Be able to think the way we think,
be able to speak the way we speak,
uh,
and,
and to understand what the issues of the day are.
And since then in this last year,
I mean,
I can go down the list of,
of the people that you know,
Eric,
who I'm sure maybe you guys know,
uh,
coined this phrase,
the intellectual dark web and there is something happening and you guys are part
of it.
That's,
that's the beauty of it.
You guys are part of it.
But this guy right here,
he really,
I think is,
is the center of it.
I mean,
this guy's got,
I think it's the number one book in the world.
I mean Bible.
Ooh.
Yep.
I don't want to say something else.
You know,
a lot of people ask me what I do college gigs or I'm out on the street or
whatever.
People will ask me about Jordan and they always asked me what does he get the
same,
you know,
off camera.
Is He the same?
And I got to tell you guys,
I know Jordan pretty well now and it had,
it's been an honor and a pleasure getting to know him and he truly is the same.
He talks as fast when he's off camera,
he moves his hands possibly even more when we're together,
Andy and he cares about this stuff and he is living this stuff.
And you know what,
just in the last couple of weeks,
how many you guys saw all these ridiculous hit pieces about Jordan?
Just last couple of
people just tell her all right.
Like just these endlessly hysterical,
dishonest.
I mean the phrase that I've been using is that these people are activists,
not journalist.
And I was really trying to think,
it's like,
well for years,
these last two years,
this guy has caught fire and it's like,
where,
where are you guys?
Where were you when,
when we were all having these conversations and then suddenly they get it right
and then they don't know what to do with it.
And the reason they don't know what to do with it do what to do with it is
because he's talking about personal responsibility.
What are these 12 rules that Jordan's going to talk about tonight?
Right?
Sit Up Straight,
get your shit together.
You know,
and that's it.
That's a beautiful thing.
But for the people that want to control you,
that's the thing that they hate the most because they don't want you to get your
shit together.
And this guy being around him has forced me in some ways to get my shit
together.
So with that in mind,
are you ready?
[inaudible]
yeah,
come on Chloe.
I think he can get them to do a little better than that.
Glowing yellow.
Little more than that.
Can you a little more upbeat?
[inaudible]
was really,
there is an idea revolution happening in this country.
You guys are part of it.
But this guy right now is the center of it and it is my honor and pleasure to
introduce Dr. Jordan Peterson.
[inaudible]
you guys,
you New Yorkers here.
A real tough crowd.
Thank you.
If this is just completely ridiculous.
Yes.
Yeah.
I came here about an hour and a half ago and there were people like the lined up
around the block.
That's don't,
what the hell are you doing?
Yeah,
look at where it's at.
I'm really looking forward to talking to you guys tonight.
Really I,
it's,
I'm hoping,
well,
get right to the bottom of the things.
That's the plan.
So if I'm going to just launch right into it,
I'm going to talk to you about my book tonight.
I'm going to go,
I'm going to try to go through all 12 rules.
Yeah.
Try not to get too digressive while I'm doing it.
You know,
each time I do this I try to hit it from a different angle and to expand on the
story to make it clearer and all of that.
So I'm gonna try to do that again tonight and start with rule one.
How am I heard somebody has lobster cause logs through teacher.
That's just quite a many ridiculous things that have been happening.
But you know the first chapter which is stand up straight with your shoulders
back.
It's,
yeah,
there's a variety of themes that I was trying to weave together.
And I think that there the three themes or something like hierarchy,
inequality and the vulnerability.
It's something like that.
And I will start with hierarchy because it's really,
really an important issue to tie.
Didn't take really into the issue of,
of inequality.
But I'll start with hierarchy.
So you know,
one of the things that Carl Marx suggested 100 years ago,
150 years ago,
and not really all that originally because other people had made the same kind
of comments was that uh,
wealth tends to accumulate in the hands of fewer and fewer people.
And he regarded that as evidence of,
of a certain type of profound unfairness APP.
You know,
you have to give the devil his due.
You really do.
You can't make the arguments of those who stand in opposition to you week.
It's foolish.
You have to make them strong because then if you counter them,
you've covered them in the best possible manner.
And the thing about marks,
observation is that it was correct.
Wealth does tend to accumulate in the hands of fewer and fewer people.
Now having said that,
there's some complexities about that that absolutely 100% has to be addressed.
The first is that it's not always in the hands of the same people.
So if you look at how many distributes itself,
imagine you're playing monopoly,
you guys have all played monopoly.
Every monopoly game ends the same way,
right?
Everybody who's playing except one person starves to death and I'm the one
person gets everything right?
But if you play 10 monopoly games that you find,
it's very seldom,
it's the same person who ends up our top across the entire set of 10 gauge and
we're not.
We actually has more in common with real life than you might think because
monopoly is essentially a game of chance,
but some skill in it.
But if you run a economic game like monopoly out to its logical conclusion,
what happens is that one person ends up with everything and everyone else ends
up with nothing.
That's actually a consequence of the randomness itself.
And that's been modeled by the way,
by people who call themselves econo physicists.
Like who knows?
But there's Econo physicists,
right?
Who would know that those sorts of people exist.
But they've used mathematical equations,
mathematical equations,
governing randomness to describe how many distributes itself in an economy.
And it does just like monopoly.
Now the real world's more complicated than monopoly.
And it's not only a random game,
um,
but,
but there's a fundamental point here.
And the point is that in complex systems,
inequality tends,
do we merge?
Now the problem with the Damn Marxists is that they laid out the feet of western
civilization and capitalism.
And that's,
that's a problem for two reasons.
The first reason it's a problem is because it's simply not true.
And that's actually a problem.
The problem with inequality is way more serious then whatever problems,
capitalism in western civilization,
how our societies aren't perfect.
But compared to most imperfect societies,
they're pretty damn good.
But the thing that,
that
they're being blamed for,
it
is not their fault.
You cannot lay inequality at the feet of capitalism.
And that's why I parked me,
I wrote about lobsters because whatever you don't see might say about lobsters,
they are not capitalists.
They don't partake in a free market economy.
And their societies aren't socio cultural constructs.
None of that is even vaguely true.
It's seriously not true.
But they still have inequality and they still have hierarchies.
And so what that means,
and it's a point I make repeated like in the chapter is hierarchical data
quality is at least a third of a billion years old.
And so
one problem.
So one of the problems with misdiagnosing,
it's cost is that you lay it at the feet of a,
of a system that is producing it,
or is it producing it any more than any other system would.
But the second is,
is that you actually failed to take it as seriously as you need to take it if
you're going to address it.
So because right or left,
one thing we should all be able to agree on as far as I'm concerned,
isn't it?
Having people stack up in poverty at the bottom of your hierarchy is not good.
Like who likes that?
Right.
Cool.
You know,
you see people marching,
I'm against poverty.
It's like really?
Who is for a porphyry?
No know.
It's not like,
it's not like well off.
People walk down the streets of New York saying they see someone homeless
shivering away suffering off to the side.
They're thinking,
Hey man,
strike one up for the capitalist is how people think.
They think they,
they're,
they're hurt by it and they don't know what to do about it.
They'll avoid it.
Maybe they won't even look,
they don't know what to do,
but they're not bloody wall celebrate again,
perhaps they don't off her money.
You know?
And there's a variety of complex reasons for that.
But that's at least in part because it's not obvious to me in a situation like
that,
money directly help or at least it's not.
It's not a foregone conclusion,
but that's the proper solution.
So no one likes poverty and the evidence on inequality has pretty strong.
From the social science perspective,
it's pretty clear that it doesn't matter what size unit of social analysis you
use,
whether it's city,
neighborhood,
city,
state,
or country.
The more inequality there is,
the more the society starts to destabilize and the more violent the men get.
And that's also not good at the reason the men get fired just because men are
more violent than women,
and so they get violent first.
But the ones at the bottom,
the once you stack up at the bottom and don't see any way of potentially
climbing to the top,
they pay.
I don't have anything to lose.
I might as well throw the whole thing up in the air.
Let's play a new monopoly game.
Maybe I'll come out on top this time.
And that's not good.
Right?
It's not good to have your society destabilized.
So we know that there was some parameters within which our societies have to
operate in order to maintain their stability.
Everybody can agree on that,
but enough with the misdiagnosis.
That's my sense.
It's like,
okay,
we can have a discussion about inequality and we can agree that it can become a
problem,
but we're not going to blame it on capitalism and we're not going to blame it on
the free market and we're not going to blame it on the patriarchy or Western
civilization because that's just wrong.
That's the first thing,
and that's,
that's really it.
That's really an important site.
Now the second thing is,
well,
how do you best probably hunted?
So we'll say that hierarchy is a permanent element of a social organization,
right?
It runs through the the Kingdom of life.
Any complex lifeforms organize themselves into a hierarchy.
The winters tend to take more than the losers.
That's how it is now.
I never once claimed,
don't know why I'm being accused of claiming that.
Well,
because that's how it is.
That's how it should be.
It's like there's a big gap between the way things are,
the way they should be.
Any anyone knows that if they're the least fit,
philosophically astute,
you can't say,
well there's beggars on the street and that's how it shouldn't be.
It's like that's completely foolish.
We want to,
we want to ameliorate the worst parts of the what the,
the painful elements of reality and so forth.
And we're able to do that.
But that's doesn't mean we know how to do it.
There's a book that was just published by a guy named Walter shutdown called the
great leveler,
believe that's the name of it.
Um,
it was just,
just came out and it's an analysis of inequality.
It's quite,
it's quite good.
It's,
it's kind of a technical book,
but I'd recommend it.
One of the things shy did,
he was curious about,
well,
is there anything that can be done about inequality?
And so here's a question,
an empirical question and scientific question.
Imagine that you stacked up left wing governments and it stacked up right wing
governments and you measured the levels of inequality among the left wing
governments and you measured levels of inequality among the right wing
governments.
You'd hope probably that there would be less inequality in the last week he
societies because after all,
what they're trying to do desperately is to decrease inequality among all sorts
of other things.
But you know,
as I said,
give the devil his due.
They're trying to reduce inequality.
Oh,
Shadelle phone.
There was no relationship whatsoever between the political stance of the
government levels of inequality and that that is not a finding to be.
Ah,
what would you say can be thankful about to be,
to gloat about,
to be happy about?
It's actually really quite catastrophic because what it means is that we don't
know how to manipulate sociopolitical systems to eliminate or even alleviate
inequality.
We simply do not know how to do it.
And that's another indication of just exactly how deep the problem is.
Now I'm going to talk about some potential solutions as we progressed.
But you know,
we,
we want to grapple with these things like intelligent human beings instead of
like ideological robots,
you know,
and we can,
we can say,
well look,
obviously the fact that some people have have that,
some people stack up at zero and zero's a really hard place to get out of that's
not in anyone's best interest self.
Evidently it's like,
okay,
well what do we do about it?
The answer is we don't know.
Now I think about the,
and,
and a lot of the things that we try to do about it make it worse.
So the other thing should I delve pointed out,
and this is one of the horrifying elements of this book,
is there are things we can do to reduce inequality,
uh,
mass plants,
reducing inequality,
right?
Right.
More reduces inequality.
Why?
Because everyone ends up at zero and that reduces inequality.
And when everyone's dead,
they're all equal.
And those aren't solutions I think that we should necessarily be pursuing.
But as far as Cardale can tell,
there aren't any self-evidently viable alternatives.
And so then we have another problem too,
which is one of the things about capitalism and about the west I would say in
general,
is that while we produce it and quality,
because we are producing inequality,
we also produce wealth.
And that's pretty new,
right?
In 1995,
the average western person lived on less than a dollar a day by today's
standards,
India,
today's money.
So that's absolute poverty.
So the typical person in 1895 was absolutely poor,
poorer than the typical person who lives on the planet now.
And so this,
this ability to produce wealth into distributed,
which is something we're actually extraordinarily good at,
is really quite new and it's really quite fragile.
What were,
were going great guns out it.
And also I worked for you in committee for about three years or no,
who was a committee for the secretary general that was,
uh,
it was,
the production of a report on sustainable economic development,
something like that.
And it started out,
it was really cold war narrative.
It was nasty left versus right narrative,
which I didn't like it all very pessimistic,
very anti human,
you know,
and we're destroying the planet.
We're horrible people in all that sort of absolute pathological rubbish.
And so,
oh Jesus.
And so we,
we,
we tried to update the narrative from like 1984 which is where it was basically
stuck,
pointed out that a lot of things are really going well.
You know,
if we have any sense collectively we'd be celebrating.
Like I follow this group on Twitter called human progress.org which I like quite
a lot.
And they tweet out real positive things.
You don't not feel good stories but like data driven,
optimistic news.
And they had a mock up of the New York Times front page recently that they
tweeted if it said 186,000 people lifted out of absolute poverty today and then
the cut line was we could run that every day for the last 20 years.
It's like you think about that,
you know,
so the number of people in absolute poverty in the world fell by 50% between the
year 2000 and the year 2012 which was three years faster than the most
optimistic projections had suggested.
It's like,
yes,
that's so good.
This isn't the same thing is happening and all sorts of fraud.
So you know the fastest
are we getting caught him.
He sit in the world right now are in sub Sahara Africa.
It's like,
and that's partly because the Africans have got a hold of computation
computational technology,
right?
Which is a massive deal.
You hold in your hand,
you hold in your hand and computational device that puts the computational
devices that were used to launch the Apollo space program absolutely to shape
right?
And everyone has one and those who don't will have one suit.
And you know,
that's one of the things that starts to make you rich and about 300,000 people,
hundreds of thousands of people a week or being hooked up to the power grid.
We're kicking the hell up chop mortality and also all cause mortality.
And extending life radically and people are literate way more literate than they
were 50 years ago across the world.
It's like a lot of really amazing things are happening harming what's happened,
I think,
and this is made things more difficult in the United States in particular,
is that a lot of the advances made by the working class in places,
say like Gideon,
China,
happy,
purchased out the expensive and increasing standard of living for American
working people.
And so they're the ones who pretty paid for this.
But,
and that's,
that's sad and it's hard,
but it's not so bad that the Chinese aren't starving.
You know,
it's not so bad that the Indians aren't starving.
There's lots of them.
And if they were in the economy and producing and moving themselves up to middle
class,
it's like that's a pretty damn good deal.
And one of the things that really shocked me,
what particularly when,
when I was helping write this report was like,
what the hell?
Why don't we know this?
Why don't we like having a little party or even a big party about it?
Instead of biting off her own legs,
which we see to be doing it the west spring.
Now with all this idiotic political polarization,
like things are not so bad.
I mean,
there was still a bloody catastrophe,
right?
Because life is a catastrophe.
But comparatively speaking,
it's like,
well,
so that's what's doing that.
Well,
I can tell you it's not communism.
It's doing that.
That's for blade shirt.
What's happening is the free market,
essentially the free market is making people rich.
It's increasing inequality at the same time,
but at least,
whoa,
it's increasing inequality.
It's stopping people from starving to death.
I mean,
that's something.
Yeah,
so that's chapter one.
Well,
there's a bit of an injunction in chapter one and rule one there.
It's like,
you know,
so
you have to battle with a number of things in your life and you have to battle
with the tragedy.
That's your life.
You know when you have to battle with the fact that you're not everything you
could be and probably never will be.
You know,
you have to battle with the fact that you've got an evil heart just like the
person next to you.
It's like there's all sorts of things if you have to contend with in life that
are very,
very difficult.
The fact of hierarchy and the fact that they would call and he'd hold up that as
well.
That's part of your intrinsic vulnerability.
Let's say it's the price you pay for BIA as far as I can tell,
but we'll talk about that later.
The question is,
well,
how do you deal with that unfairness?
Let's say that the intrinsic unfairness,
well,
people are quite creative.
I mean some of the things we do to combat that's essential inequalities.
We generate a lot of different games.
You know,
like animals basically played one game and you're either good at it or you're
not,
but human beings,
we played hundreds of games and if you're not good at one,
you can maybe find another one that you're at least not so bad at.
Or at least improving out or maybe you can invent your own game.
And so that's a pretty creative thing to do and we're pretty damn good at that.
And so that's one solution.
But another solution to is this too.
The question is if,
if the environment arrays itself into a hierarchy,
how is it that you're best situated to play within that hierarchy?
You know,
in one answer might be to make yourself powerful,
you know,
in the physical sense or in the,
in the menacing and threatening sense because especially the people who
criticize hierarchy always presume that what makes you dominant in the hierarchy
is something like raw power,
which by the way is just not true.
It's true to a limited sense among some animals.
It's really not true when human beings,
it's not even true among complex primates because what's been found about
chimpanzees for example,
is that the brutal tyrant chimps tend to be ripped to shreds by there,
by the,
by the chimpanzees that there tyrannizing as soon as they have a weak moment.
And you don't have to have much of an imagination to see how that plays out.
On the human stage.
And so it actually turns out that if you want to climb a hierarchy,
let's say that the hierarchy isn't the power hierarchy,
not not in a functioning society,
it's more like a competence hierarchy or more like a voluntary game.
And the way that you climb it actually believe it or not is by being a good
person.
And you might think,
well that's a little naive.
It's like,
yeah,
no it's not really that night.
First of all,
it's not that easy to be a good person.
And the second is it's,
it's somewhat self evident.
You know,
like you know people that you trust and you don't trust.
And like once you don't trust someone,
you really don't trust them.
It's really hard for them to recover from that.
And if you don't trust them,
you're not going to play with them.
None.
If you have any sense.
And we're really good at relationship tracking and we're especially good at
tracking behavior that's ethically suspect.
And we remember it like one mistake of blowing your reputation,
you know,
it's harsh,
but it just shows you how important trust is.
And if you act in a trustworthy manner,
and I'm not saying this is enough to make your life,
you know,
all sparkles and,
and,
and rainbows.
It's like forget that that ain't happening no matter what you do.
But if you're,
if you're someone that can be trusted,
then the probability that you'll at least move towards some degree of success in
your domain is radically increased.
And so that's a good deal.
And then the other thing too is that makes you a contender in a,
in a hierarchical game is a kind of courage.
And it's a funny courage cause it's,
it's paradoxical curves.
This is one of the things I really liked about the narrative structure of
Christianity,
I would say,
because I think Christianity has done a very good job of detailing out this idea
is that if you,
the competence that you need to manifest in life,
the courage that you need to manifest in life.
And that goes along with being someone that can be trusted,
is to be someone who will stand up and expose themselves.
So
let's try a different term
who will accept their vulnerability,
right?
And take that on as part and parcel of their responsibility.
And part of that for human beings is to stand up,
you know,
because the most vulnerable part of us is faced forward.
We're unlike our other creatures,
right?
Because other animals they pour on on all four and their back is armored and
that's what they present to the world essentially.
But not us.
We stepped up and make the most vulnerable parts of us front and forward.
And there's a kind of courage in that.
But because I'm willing to take on the catastrophe of existence forthrightly,
and that's what rule one is,
that's,
it's not,
it's not a finger wagging injunction for stand up straight.
You know,
because there's something wrong with you if you don't.
Although there is,
it's an encouragement to say,
look,
the way that you find out how strong you can be is to accept how vulnerable you
are.
And if you think about it,
that makes perfect sense because we are self aware creatures.
We know perfectly well how badly we can be hurt when we also know that we will
be broken.
It's not just that we could be bird.
It's way worse than not.
It's that we most certainly will be hurt in terrible ways.
And to be able to stand up and take that,
you know,
and to take that like someone who's courageous,
it's like,
well that'll,
that'll float your boat man.
That'll make people respect you.
That'll increase the probability that they'll trust you and it will allow you to
sleep with a good conscience at ninth and that's something,
and maybe that's about as good as it gets.
And so that's rule one.
Rule two is an extension of that.
You know,
it,
it's,
it's treat yourself as if you have someone responsible for helping and
okay,
you hear it from psychologists frequently that,
you know,
people are kind of narcissistic and they tend to overestimate their skills in
relationship to other people and so forth.
I don't really buy any of that.
I,
I don't,
I don't think it's true.
I think most of that's a measurement garden.
In fact,
I think instead that people,
my sense of people from my clinical perspective and from my research perspective
is actually Jeff or the opposite of that.
If you,
if you sit down and you have a serious conversation with someone,
it doesn't take very long if you have a serious conversation,
unless they're narcissistic and in,
in really pathological manner.
Most people aren't like that.
They're so damn painfully aware of what's wrong with them that it's hard to
even,
it's hard to even face,
you know,
you don't have to talk to someone for very long until they tell you what they've
done wrong or how they're inadequate.
It's not some whiny game,
although sometimes it's that it's,
it's genuine recognition of their shortcomings and false.
No.
The with being an individual person is that,
well,
you kind of are aware of the fragility of human beings in general and then not
only that for fragility,
but also is there tendency towards malevolence because it isn't the only that
we're vulnerable.
We're vulnerable and we're capable of doing terrible things,
not to ourselves but also to other people.
And not only are we capable of doing that,
we've all done it and we know it.
And so you've got that to carry around,
you know,
the fact that you aren't everything you could be.
And that's for sure.
And the fact that you know you've done some things that really aren't that pride
worthy,
let's say,
and you bloody well know it.
Even if you're trying to fight it,
if you're trying to avoid it,
you might even be more painfully aware of it then you should be.
You know,
because sometimes I've also seen it with people is they're much more willing to
forgive other people than they are willing to forgive themselves.
So I'm telling you think,
well so this chapter's well.
Treat yourself like you're someone responsible for helping you think.
Well that's self evidence.
Like it's not so self evident.
I open the chapter with this observation that if you have a pet,
if you go to a doctor and you get a prescription medication,
well there's one third chance that you won't fill it.
And if you do fill it,
there's a 50% chance you won't take the medication.
And so you think,
well,
maybe there's a bunch of reasons for that.
You don't trust the doctor,
you're lazy,
you don't understand what's going on,
who knows?
But here's the weird thing.
That's not true.
If you take your pet to the that if you take your pat to the Vat,
well then you'll go fill the prescription and you'll give the damn pet the
medication.
It's like,
okay,
what's going on there?
Do you like your dog more than you like you?
So like,
yeah,
maybe even a lot,
you know love.
And there's some reason for that because you know,
if you have a dog or a cat,
let's say a dog in this case,
like the dog,
is it innocent creature?
It's a carnivore,
but it's an innocent creature.
I get t doesn't have sins zone.
It's conscience.
You don't expect the dog to be everything.
It could be.
I said dog,
if that's where this this,
you do it right.
You know,
it's pretty happy when it sees you and it's a pretty fair exchange of our
factors.
There's no reason to distrust the dog.
I mean it might do foolish dog things like chew a toy when it's not supposed to,
but that's about as far as sin goes for a dog.
And so they're easy to like and you're,
you're not so easy.
Like that's for sure.
Yeah.
That's,
you can tell that cause your family members,
they're happier to see if the dog that they aren't seeing.
So,
you know,
you got it,
you've got this,
you've got this tough problem,
which is what you got to put up with yourself.
And it's even worse than that because you know who you are.
It's like,
oh my God,
who's gonna take care of that?
No one.
It's like,
well just let it walk her off into a corner somewhere.
Die.
But you know,
it's not a good thing.
One of the things I learned from Carl Young,
he,
he talked about this is Christian junction.
It's from a psychological perspective,
which is to treat,
treat other people like you would like to be treated.
And,
and you know,
people often think of that as this injunction to be nice to other people.
It's like that is not what that means.
First of all,
nice has a very low and virtue man.
Nice as heartless as far as I'm concerned.
That's,
that's not a virtue.
It's the absence of a particular fault at best
to treat yourself,
to treat yourself like you.
Treat others like you'd like to be treated yourself is an equation.
So let's say I've enjoyed in some sense to treat you properly,
but,
but I'm also joined to treat myself properly and so then I'd have to think that
through.
It's like,
let's say you have a child,
you have a son and you want to treat a properly.
It's like,
well you don't just let them get away with everything.
That's not helpful.
You want to sit and think about what sort of person you would like this child to
be calm.
You want to encourage that,
right?
You want to act as if you're charged with the care of something valuable and
precious and then you do what you can.
If you have any sense to help that person become everything they can become,
it's like,
well you have the same responsibility to yourself.
Even as you know,
even even though you might not think you deserve it,
it doesn't have anything to do with deserving it.
It's some sense,
it's a moral requirement to view yourself despite your inadequacies and your
faults as if you're someone who needs to be properly taken care of and,
and,
and it's a responsibility on your part to figure out what that is.
And this actually works.
You know,
we have this program we designed called self authoring and I designed it with
two of my colleagues,
Daniel Higgins and Robert Peel.
One was a graduate student of mine,
that's Daniel Higgins and the other was my graduate supervisor at McGill.
And we worked on that for about 20 years figuring out how to make it accessible
to individuals on the web.
We want it to bring psychological interventions to people that were low cost and
effective.
And we have this,
part of this program is the future authoring program.
And it's two parts.
It's a writing program because writing,
by the way,
if you want to straighten out your brain,
there's almost nothing you can do that's better than writing.
Writing really straightens you out.
You're organized at the highest level of your personality,
your organized verbally.
And so you have to,
you have to have an account of yourself.
You have to have an articulated the counting yourself of yourself.
That's why you talk to people all the time about what's going on in your life.
It's so that you can have an articulated account of yourself.
And if you're disorganized at the level of the articulated account that you're
disorganized,
you might think,
well,
who cares?
It's like,
no,
no.
You don't understand.
If you're disorganized,
you fall into a pit.
Like it's a bad thing.
It's like you have a map,
but there's stains everywhere.
There's big holes torn in it and it's half drawn in Crayon and like you're not
getting anywhere good with a map like that.
And so you have to be able to articulate yourself.
And so,
and writing is a very good way of doing that.
And in the cell for three program,
you could write about your past and you could write about your personality and
then you can write about your future.
Now,
you know,
one of the things I've learned from dealing with students forever is that in
our,
in our education system,
this is so weird,
I,
I've really struggled with this realization.
I've had it about 15 years ago.
We never said,
I have these students who have been in it in formal education for 16 years,
right?
And no one has ever sat them down even once and said,
okay,
look,
you've got three hours,
right about who the hell you should be.
And I don't mean you're going to be a plumber or a lawyer or whatever.
Fair enough.
You know,
that is what I mean.
It's like,
you know,
what kind of character do you want to manifest in the world in detail,
and then why you think,
well,
why don't we teach people to do this?
It's like,
it's the only question,
zoning relevant question.
It's like,
well if you can be who you could be,
let's imagine you had that within the palm of your hands since it would be
possible for you to be who you could be.
Let's say that's within you realm of,
of,
of competence.
Who would that be?
And if that answer is,
well I don't know and that's the answer,
then give it up man.
Cause it,
cause you're not going to move forward with a plan like that.
You know like I think this is a psychological truth.
We know already that human perception is organized around aim.
Everything about us is organized around and even the way we use our eyes,
it's organized around the aim.
We're,
we're,
we're aiming creatures and how do you not hit something if you,
if you're,
if there's a target there,
how do you miss it?
Well one is not specified at the target.
So I,
how are you going to hit something if you don't specify it?
So it's like,
I know that for most people,
life is something that happens to them.
They're reacting to things all the time,
which means that they're tangled up in someone else's story,
or they're pawns in someone else's aims,
or they're pawns of the aims of their own unconscious processes not to.
And then,
you know,
that's the case when you find yourself doing something that you can't believe
you did.
Right.
I can't believe I did that.
It's like,
yeah,
well there's something Indian that had you,
it wasn't you or it was a dark part of,
you know,
but there's nothing to replace that.
There's no super ordinate aim.
And so in the future authoring program,
we get people to,
well,
just to think about their lives,
it's like,
so there's this,
another injunction in the new testament is very strange.
One Says No,
Aka the door will open ask and you will receive if think,
yeah,
fat chance,
right?
Who's going to believe that?
Right?
It's just to,
it's way too looks to naively optimistic to even possibly be true,
but,
but it's a strange thing.
And I've seen this over and over in my clinical and my consulting practice and
with my students,
I'll tell you that if you don't aim at something,
you will not hit it.
And if you do a mad,
the probability that you'll at least get advanced in that direction,
it starts to,
you will.
That's what will happen.
Now you aim at something,
what the Hell do you know?
Right?
You set up your aim,
you don't know anything.
And he's like,
you're stupid in your aims just like you are and everything else.
But at least you're aiming at something.
You move towards it.
And as you move towards it,
you learn something because you're actually doing something.
You might learn precisely how stupid you were in your aims,
but you learn it precisely.
And that's so useful because once you learn something precisely like that,
then you can incorporate the knowledge and you can reformulate your aim.
And the next name is not quite so bone headed.
And so what you do is imagine you should be aiming here,
but you don't know cause you're blind.
And maybe that's even moving.
And so you're so blind,
you aim over here or you walk a little ways that you think no wrong.
Then you even over here,
you walk a little ways and you think no wrong.
And You keep doing that.
And like it's a winding path.
He's like,
it's not the shortest point B,
not the shortest distance between point a and B,
but you're moving forward.
And so even if you're doing it badly,
you're approximating the ideal.
And the more you do that,
the better you get at it.
And that actually works.
And so we ask people,
you know,
when you think,
well,
what's life?
You know,
what,
what's,
what's your life made out of?
Well,
it's pretty straight forward.
You know,
you need,
you need some relationships,
right?
You've got to have some friends.
That'd be good.
Maybe some of you don't want friends.
Okay.
You're a peculiar sort and you don't need friends.
But from her daughter are some people who aren't that social,
you know?
But broadly speaking,
a couple of friends is a good thing.
Okay.
How many and who?
Who should get them for friends?
Oh,
you might take while people who are kind of on your side,
that'd be good.
Or maybe people who are at least aren't actively conspiring against you,
you know,
and you think,
well,
my friends go actively conspiring against me.
It's like,
yeah,
well you just think about it for a while and see if that's true.
It's same with your family members,
so you as well,
right?
Because you're actively conspiring against yourself as well.
So what if you could have the friends you wanted and you were doing the things
you want to quit?
Is that,
what would that look like?
All right,
well what about your career or job?
Like what's that gonna look like you,
how are you gonna make sure you are as educated as you are,
intelligent,
something like that,
are you to take care of yourself mentally and physically?
If you could do it whatever way you want it,
how are you going to handle temptations,
drug and alcohol abuse,
for example?
How are we going to regulate that?
What are you going to do with your time outside of work that's productive and
meaningful?
Well that's,
that's not a bad start at six dimensions,
you know,
it's like,
okay,
you can have,
where do you want or you can have what you need if you were taking care of
yourself,
but you have to specify,
okay,
so we tested that.
We,
we made this program,
we tested it in Holland,
first tested in three universities and under pretty rocky conditions in one
college.
We just had kids come in for the summer orientation and just spend like an hour
writing.
So you're hardly even start,
you know,
with,
with your plan.
But it's a plan and that means you're the planner.
That's a good thing to learn.
You're not just this thing that's being pushed back and forth by the bilingual
fate.
You've got the grip on things and you're at least contending.
So like,
well people were 25% more likely to stay in the university and the effect lasted
more than two years.
So that was amazing.
And great grades went up as well about the same amount and the people that had
helped the most,
which was really weird because usually if you do a psychological intervention,
you say that people not do it so well.
There's people who are doing pretty well.
You do an intervention.
The people who are doing well do even better and the people who aren't doing so
well,
they just stay where they are.
But that isn't what happened with this intervention is the people that weren't
doing very well get way better.
It was like,
well they never had a plan.
So they make a halfhearted plant.
He's like,
they're way better.
Well,
so that's something to think about.
You don't want to take care of yourself because you should or because you're
compassionate or cause it's a moral or because you're compassionate.
Let's say you want to take care of yourself because,
well this is,
this is at the center of things as far as I'm concerned,
and this is something I truly believe despite my black heart and essential
pessimism is that you know,
every human being is a spectacular miracle.
That's really the case.
That's part of the secret.
That's part of the secret of the West is our legal system is predicated on that
idea.
It's predicated on the idea that you're made in the image of God,
let's say.
And then even the law has to stay a distance from you because you're just that
remarkable.
And I believe that that's as close.
That's literally true and metaphorically true at the same time.
And I think that everyone knows this because if you don't treat yourself like
that,
you don't do very well.
And if you have friends or family members and you don't treat them like that's
true,
they don't like him very much.
And if you organize a society on axiomatic principals that don't,
that don't include that idea that those societies become unproductive and
murderous almost instantly.
And so to me that indicates this.
There's something true about that.
Let's call it metaphysical claim.
And if it's true,
well then you have an obligation to take care of yourself.
And it's not just for you.
That's the thing.
It's not selfish exactly.
Although it is because you should take care of yourself.
But if you don't take care of yourself then like what the hell are you to your
family,
you know,
and what are you good are you to your community?
And it's like you might be really useful to your family.
You never know.
You know,
you might be that the thing that stands in between them and some catastrophe and
for all you know,
you might be that,
that thing that stands in between your society and that catastrophe.
And I actually think that that's the case.
You know,
I read the great commentators on the 20th century catastrophes,
right and left wing alike and the really profound ones all say the same thing.
Society's degenerate it to hell.
When individuals abdicate their moral responsibility.
It's like there's a direct connection between you stepping up to the plate,
say it,
relationship to yourself at the stability of the world.
And I actually think it goes beyond that.
I truly believe this.
I think we don't construe who we are properly.
We don't know.
We don't articulate it properly even though we act it out.
I think that what you confront in life is something like an infinite landscape
of potential.
That's the future.
You don't live in the present,
the presence already here and the past.
It's too late,
but the future is right in front of you and you're,
you're interacting with that potential future.
It could go this way or it could go that way and you can see those potentials
manifest themselves in front of you and you make these decisions about which
part of that you're going to make into concrete reality.
And so I don't think that it's just,
it isn't just your stability that your decisions depending on,
it's not just your family's stability and flourishing.
It's not just society.
It's not.
Those are all important things and they all stack up.
I think that you play a role in directing the structure of reality itself,
and I think you bloody well know that.
And we call each other on it all the time saying,
you're not living up to your possibility.
You're not living up to your potential.
It's like,
what the hell does that mean?
Everyone says it.
Everyone's embarrassed because they know it's true.
You're not living up to your party.
I know.
God.
You know,
I know.
Don't bother me about it.
It's like you're ashamed of that.
Well,
why wouldn't you be ashamed of it?
You are.
Why?
Well,
because it actually matters.
Like it really matters unless you think that it's okay for things to degenerate
and we'll talk about that in a little it a little bit.
So that's rule too.
It's like that's worth and like,
look,
I came to this realization it wasn't an easy realization to come to you because
it just doesn't seem that self evident.
But I'm telling you when people like Viktor Frankl and Alexandra social
medicine,
Vaclav Havel people who really grappled with the horrors of the 20th century,
trying to understand how a society like East Germany could emerge,
where one in three people was a government informer.
Imagine that you get six people in your family and two of them are informing on
you to the government.
How does the society,
how does that happen?
Well,
it happens because if the individuals in the society abdicated their moral
responsibility,
that's how it happens.
You might take.
Well,
a lot of people have to do that.
It's like,
yeah,
we don't know how many people have to do that before.
Things tilt seriously sideways and it might not have to be that many and it does
matter.
I see people,
this is actually,
I decided to do what I did with regards to these.
He stamps on compelled speech in Canada.
You know,
people would be panicking,
patted me on my dock for my bravery and I'm saying,
no,
no you don't.
You don't have to stamp.
It's like it's not bravery.
It's fear of the right things.
That's wisdom.
Wisdom is fear of the right things.
You think what you think that it's dangerous to say what you have to say.
But say he just tried not saying what you have to say.
He just tried out for 10 years and see where the hell you go.
Because every time you have something to say,
which is something to live right,
there's no difference.
There's no difference.
Every time you have something to say something to live in,
you step backwards.
Well,
they don't want to cause any trouble,
you know?
And Fair enough.
You know,
because don't go causing too much trouble,
but it's cleaning out you.
You have something to say.
It's like,
no,
I don't need to do what.
I don't want the conflict.
I don't want the trouble.
It's like fine,
no problem.
No problem.
You're an inch shorter.
And the people who are conspiring,
let's say against your essential best interests are three inches taller.
You think no will see it.
See something in the future.
It's no you won't because you'll end up an inch tall facing a monster.
And if you can't speak now,
what the hell makes you think you're going to speak when that is the situation?
[inaudible]
so when
you started it
to oppose,
would I decided to oppose this legislation?
I thought,
well I got,
you know,
catastrophe to the left could catastrophe to the right and that's good thing to
know about life.
That's a good thing to know is that lots of times,
so that's what you've got.
There is no easy way forward.
There is no easy way forward in life,
period that that just doesn't exist.
You get to pick your catastrophe.
And I knew by that point that I'd rather have the catastrophe of say what I have
to say that in the catastrophe of not saying it.
And that's not bravery.
It's just why do you,
well,
it's openminded attention,
right?
It's like it's,
it's wisdom garnered from looking at how things go catastrophic.
Raul and deciding that I'd rather not participate in that.
So,
so brutal.
Three,
make friends with the people who want the best for you.
That's a hard chapter.
You don't because it's an extension of the moral obligation idea.
This,
this psychologist named Carl Rogers and Carl Rogers had this idea that in
therapy you should have unconditional positive regard for your clients.
And he didn't really act that way.
And that's because you actually can't.
And,
but,
but there was something about what Roger said was,
was right.
It wasn't formulated quite right here.
You want to have,
so I reformulated and I think I got a closer to what it should be.
When I see my clinical clients or when I interact with people in general,
what I try to do is to take,
well,
there's part of you working for you and there's part of you that isn't working
for you.
That's that eternal divide in the human psyche.
Right?
There's a division in all of us between good and evil essentially,
which is a real division.
It's a real division,
that's for sure.
What I want to be with my clients is I want to be on the side of the part of
them that's on their side and I'm not on the side of the part of them that's not
on their side at all.
It's right.
That part can just go,
that part can just go to hell.
Right,
right.
Which is where it's headed and so and that's the thing that you also want from
your friends.
I think again,
that that falls under the rubric of moral obligation.
You know,
you want to have friends.
This doesn't mean you shouldn't help people.
That that isn't what I mean.
I don't mean that at all because everybody needs a hand from time to time.
But
you are obliged to surround yourself with people who are aiming up
fundamentally,
even in their flawed way.
You know,
like everybody's got their problems,
but you're obliged to be around people that are aiming up.
If you're not.
Part of that is you don't want the ethical burden of surrounding yourself with
people who are aiming up cause they make you look bad.
And that's not an excuse to have friends that aren't good for you.
It's also not an excuse to have family members that aren't good for you.
You know,
and I've had did my clinical practice and in particular I've had situations
where the best thing for my client to do was to cut themselves off from almost
all of their family almost completely.
There was just no other possible way because they were surrounded by people who
were hell bent on destruction.
And so you think,
well,
you know these people you love.
It's like,
yeah,
fair enough.
You know,
I get that.
And it's no fun being alone and it's no fun.
Distancing yourself from people you love that hate you.
But,
but,
but
okay.
And so that's rule of three and he's like,
what's a hard book?
This one?
So Harsh Cook,
Huh?
Rule for,
compare yourself to who
you were yesterday,
not to who's someone else's today.
So I formulated that rule because,
because I'm just thinking about hierarchy again.
So we already talked about the downside of new hierarchy.
The downside is while there's some people on the top and there's some people at
the bottom and the bottom is a painful place to be.
And so what are the consequences of erecting a hierarchy is that you erect a
structure of inequality and then that can get really steep and out of control.
That's a big risk,
right?
So you might think,
well,
let's get flat and the hierarchies,
so everyone's equal.
Well then you think,
well,
first of all,
you really,
you want to flatten all the hierarchy,
which hierarchies you can leave in time,
any of them.
You should be no differences between people at all,
really?
Or we're going to draw some line.
There were some differences are okay at other differences aren't okay.
Who's going to draw those lines?
Exactly.
I mean exactly who's going to draw those lines and answer that is the people
that you least want to draw those lines,
that'll be the answer because they'll be the only ones interested in doing it.
So,
but then,
but we can give more deeply into it too.
So here,
here's a,
here's a peculiarity about human beings.
So we could start from,
we can start from a dark place,
cause that's always realistic.
People believe in dark places,
man.
Everyone believes you believe in your pain.
No one doesn't believe in their pain,
right?
Nobody's an agnostic with regards to their pain.
Everyone believes that it's real or acts like it.
So we could start their life is painful,
had PR it.
It's emotionally painful,
it's anxiety provoking.
And then of course there's the malevolence aspect,
which makes it even worse.
And so that's the baseline and you're stuck with it.
And there are times when it will become excruciating,
right?
To the point of being unbearable.
You know,
you see people fight at a death bed.
That's a good example of a nice combination of catastrophe.
And malevolence right?
Because it's already pretty bad.
Someone's dying and that's bad.
It's like,
yeah,
but little work you can make it a lot worse.
So I've often wondered,
you know,
just exactly what would be left of the tragedy of life if people just didn't
make things worse.
And one of the things I have observed as a clinician is that people can tolerate
quite a lot of tragedy,
but they can't tolerate very much having everyone make it worse just for the
sake of making it worse.
Right.
And that really hurts people if you're around people who are bringing you down
just for the sake of seeing you suffer,
that really does hurt people a lot.
That's my level.
It's,
I think that's the best definition of evil really is to produce suffering for
the sake of the suffering.
It's like an art form.
It really is.
It's the right way to think about it.
People don't like to think that way because well,
for obvious reasons,
like who would make an art form of evil?
It's like,
how about the guy who shot up the elementary school in Connecticut?
How about him?
You don't think that was an artistic statement.
You just don't have the imagination for it.
If you don't think that,
I mean,
just think about it,
right?
You're going to make an artistic statement that's associated with malevolence.
Well,
who are you going to hurt?
Well on?
Not adults.
These,
they're guilty of something for God's sake.
You don't want to go after the adults,
even if they're innocent adults.
No,
he'd go after children,
elementary school children.
You really want to make a statement that's malevolent.
Then you do the worst thing he could think of to the people who deserve it the
least.
And if you don't think that there's an aesthetic element to that,
like a considered a deeply considered aesthetic element,
then well then you have thought about it very much and I can understand why he's
like,
who wants to think that way?
But you know,
we need to understand these things because they keep happening and,
and you don't understand them without going very dark places.
Chapter six in my book is called putting your house in perfect order before you
criticize the world.
And it's actually about the mass murderers.
And why they do what they do.
And I know why they do what they do.
I'm actually make a case for it in the chapter.
It's like,
here's the reason,
here's it's perfectly understandable.
Life is very,
very,
very difficult and it's often unfair and were brutalized at the hands of other
people.
It's like that's enough to produce resent,
but even the people who are doing well,
but there are people who are not doing so well and they've had pretty damn roof
lights and may be brutalized the law and their lights and being trashed to
tragic and they beat betrayed and they get really,
really,
really bitter about it and not the sort of better that,
you know,
it keeps you up for a night or to be an angry but the kind of bitter that keeps
you in your mother's basement for like two years doing nothing but fantasizing
about how you'd like to take for advantage.
You could give some pretty terrible places with two years of sustained effort
and there's a reason for it.
There's a reason driving it.
You know what the reason is is well,
in escapable brutality of life,
well,
there's a reason,
but there's no excuse for it because just because things are terrible doesn't
mean that you're justified in making them worse.
So,
and that's another central element,
I would say up the ethic that has to unite us.
No,
you don't have the right to use your tragedy to make the world a worse place.
[inaudible]
say that.
I say that.
I don't say that lightly because I know that people can have brutally difficult
lives and it's,
some people have lives that are so brutally difficult that it's almost done
imaginable.
But some of those people,
and I've met people like that,
they've had lives so difficult that you just can't,
you can hardly imagine it.
You know,
almost everything about their life is a catastrophe.
I met this one woman,
I won't tell you quick story about her.
She was an amazing person.
So she,
I met her in this outpatient clinic I worked with,
worked for us,
the Douglas Hospital at Montreal and the Douglas Hospital as an inpatient
psychiatric hospital that was building in the mid 20th century.
It had hundreds and hundreds of inmates at one point,
patients,
let's say,
but they were all basically released in the 60s during deinstitutionalization
psychiatric drugs started to become popular.
Some of that was good,
some of it wasn't so good,
but there were some patients left at the Douglas Hospital and they were people
who were so badly damaged that they couldn't be the institutionalized.
And what you've seen street people and you know how bad the damage they are.
They at the institutionalized.
So just imagine for a minute how badly damaged you would have to be to not be
deinstitutionalized.
I don't know if you've ever seen photographs by Diane Arbus.
She went across the United States and photograph people who were,
well there were strange and and hurt people generally speaking.
And the the,
the people who were left at the Douglas,
they were,
they were like Diane,
Diane Arbus photographic subjects,
so hurt and so destroyed by decades of mental illness and they,
the buildings and the Douglas Hospital.
We're connected by underground passages,
partly because it's so bloody cold in Montreal and winter.
You didn't want everybody freezing to death when they were moving from one
building to another.
There are a lot of vending machines and so forth downstairs,
and that's where the inpatients would congregate.
And walking through there,
it was like walking through Dante's inferno,
like it was a real,
it was really well as surreal.
Like there's no other way to put it.
I took my brother with me once he,
well,
he wasn't accustomed to this sort of thing at all.
It just shell shocked him,
you know,
and no wonder.
So these people were in very rough shape.
Anyways,
this woman came to see me,
I have to at the outpatient clinic and so she had her problems,
but she wasn't,
they weren't severe enough so that she was an institutionalized inpatient,
but she had her problem with span.
So she kind of looked like a street person.
She had this red down jacket on.
It was really dirty and her clothes were dirty and she wasn't an attractive
person.
And she was the young person and she was so shy that like shy doesn't even begin
to,
to describe it.
Like she was a whole universe of shy.
So she would walk up to people like this.
It was like she couldn't stand the light that was emanating from him.
She was so shy that that was the best she could do,
you know,
to,
to approach someone like this.
Of course,
if she's out on the street approaching people like this,
it's like she's not getting a positive response,
you know,
because people don't know what the hell to make of that.
Especially because she's also uncapped him,
you know,
and,
and not very verbal and God.
So she came to see me and we were trying to fish.
It wasn't very articulate and she wasn't very bright,
um,
at,
we're trying to figure out what she wanted.
And so for a while what I was trying to do is to get her to stand up a bit and
didn't take her hand away from her face just so that she looked a little bit
more normal so that she had a better chance of having,
you know,
like a reasonable interaction with people.
But I talked to her for awhile.
She told me a little bit about her life.
I mean,
God,
she was,
I've employed obviously,
and her,
she lived with her aunt who was like deathly ill and her and her mom had a
boyfriend who was a violent schizophrenia who was an alcoholic and all he ever
did was like harass her about her being in league with Satan,
which was just what you need when you have all of those other problems.
Right.
Because you know,
anyways,
it was like,
you just listen to this.
He's just like,
Oh God.
It's like,
could this possibly be any worse?
And the answer is yes.
It could be good to be worse even.
But once,
here's what she wanted.
This is the thing.
When went to,
after I talked to her,
like for five or six sessions,
it turned out she didn't even come to the damn behavior therapy clinic to get
help.
She didn't want hell.
She had this dog and she used to walk the dog around.
She liked the dog and she had been in the inpatient ward from time to time
because he's been committed to the hospital,
you know,
but then she went to the inpatient ward.
She saw all these other people who were worse off than her.
It's hard to imagine,
but that's what she saw.
She saw these people that were worse off than her and what she wanted.
She was trying to find somebody who is an administrator at the hospital that
would give her permission to take one of the inpatients out for a walk when she
wake to walk her dog and that one was her.
It's like,
Jesus,
no right.
Telling you.
When she told me that story,
it's like,
I don't know what the hell you think of someone like that because you know she
was so rude.
Did her presentation and she could see,
she could see outside her own misery.
And as intense as it was,
she could see outside their own misery.
And her decision was,
well,
maybe there's a way that I could make something a little bit better for someone
worse off than me.
Wow.
You know,
I never forgot her.
I'll never forget her.
She just absolutely blew me away.
Well,
what
is it?
The bigger person,
she wasn't
the bitter person by any stretch of the imagination.
Okay.
Well,
so back to hierarchies.
there's lots of ways that you can be successful in a hierarchy,
you know,
and she was asked to clean successful.
I would say it,
that's for sure.
And that's really something.
And she didn't let her own suffering.
Dominique,
her psychological reality and,
and determined that the best move forward was to extract revenge on the world.
You know what?
She decided to play a straight game.
So there was something,
you know,
I hesitate to say st like about her,
but good God.
You know what I mean?
She had everything you could possibly imagine not going for her and still like
how do you manage that?
How do you,
how well you,
as far as I could tell when he decide,
like it's not that simple,
you know,
but there's an element of decision that goes into that.
Maybe it's a thousand decisions or 100,000 decisions,
you know,
a little tiny micro decisions that enables someone to stay on the right side of
reality even though so many things are stacked up against them.
Well,
so she wasn't bitter.
Okay,
well back to the hierarchy or idea.
Well
life is full of,
right.
We've already established that.
And the question is what do you have to,
to set against that?
What do you have to set against that is actually what hierarchies provide for
you.
So because you can't set happiness against tragedy,
that doesn't work because you're not happy when there's a tragedy.
And so that just doesn't work right?
You're not going to be happy all that often.
And when it come to like that's really good and all of that and you should enjoy
it and thank God for it.
And all of that,
but you can't use it as a has a boat in a storm.
Like that's not happening.
You got to have something else.
Well,
the thing about a hierarchy of value hierarchy because it will hierarchies,
value hierarchies.
Something at the top is better and something at the board of his worst.
That's really what defines her.
Her key is having a hierarchy gives you a name I'm giving you.
They give you name.
It gives you a purpose and like we know this,
even we know this neuro biologically,
let's say
if the baseline condition of life is suffering,
you have to have something to offset it and what do you have to offset it is
whatever value I hierarchy offers you because you need something to aim at.
You need something to a map that makes the suffering worthwhile.
That's like,
that's like the meaning of life.
You say,
well,
what's the meaning of life?
It's to have something to end up that makes the suffering worthwhile so that you
can,
when you're in the midst of your limited life,
you could say,
yeah,
but this,
this is worthwhile.
This makes it worthwhile.
And it's not something that you think exactly.
It's something you've noticed,
right?
Cause you,
you can watch your life for a couple of weeks detached have,
you can watch and you can,
you can ask yourself,
okay,
when,
where is it that I am,
when I'm doing something that justifies itself?
Maybe it's playing music.
That's often the case for people that are listening to music.
Or maybe you're with someone you love or maybe you're working on something that
you're really engaged in.
I don't know.
What would it be different for different people?
But you can be sure that you're having,
if something worthwhile and you're on the pathway to managing it.
And that's the thing about human beings.
That's where we get our positive emotion is we,
we aim at something the time and then we moved towards it.
And if we see ourselves successfully moving towards it,
then that engages us with the meeting that makes life worthwhile.
And what that means is that if you don't have a hierarchy of value and you don't
have anything to aim for,
then all you're left with is stupid suffering.
Because like,
that's not eradicable right.
There's no way of getting rid of that quality be down.
Like if everyone had everything and we were all the same,
what?
We'd still be suffering with the burden of being human and being alive,
that you're not getting rid of that the only thing you could do without is
justify it.
And the only way you can justify something that's that terrible is to be
pursuing something that's good enough to make that justifiable.
Well,
who knows what that will be.
I learned that partly,
strangely enough,
I learned that partly from watching Pinocchio,
which I spent a lot of time watching.
I have a Youtube Video About Pinocchio,
and there's a scene in Tokyo where it was a very strange story,
and it's full of Biblical allegories and deep myths and all sorts of things,
but there's a scene in,
but Akio where'd you,
Japan lifts his eye up and wishes on a star.
You know,
any wishes that his puppet would become a genuine human being?
And that's a very deep idea.
But the whole way that's acted out is extraordinarily telling because a star
think a star or something that glitters in the darkness,
right?
It and it's part of the cosmos is part of the eternal cosmic structure,
which you sense when you look up,
right?
Everyone who looks into the night sky has a sense of awe associated with
confronting the infinite,
let's say something like that.
So it started something that partakes of the infinite and it's,
it's above the horizon,
right?
So it's something you lift your eyes too.
So it's a high aim.
And so what [inaudible] does is take as the highest aim,
the,
the hope that the puppet that he's created could become genuine.
And there's something about that that's extraordinarily deep.
I mean that's the hope you have for a child,
if you have any sense,
is that the person grows up to become an autonomous and fully functioning,
responsible,
awake,
aware,
conscious human being.
Not The puppet of some idiot belief system or the puppet of any person,
but someone who who's admirable and competent and truthful,
all of those things,
that's a high aim.
Well,
that's an aim that maybe would justify your life,
say,
well,
in the face of your suffering,
you have this terrible cross to bear him and say,
well,
who the hell could you be in the face of all that?
You could be something strong enough to bear it and hopefully that'd be
something.
Who would you be if you were that person?
God only knows it's really,
it's a task fit for a cake.
It really is because it's so,
it's such an impossible thing to,
to imagine yourself managing,
but yet here we are.
You know,
and that's,
and that's what's in front of us as our calling.
It's right in front of us.
Well,
you need a hierarchy because you need something to,
hey man,
you need something to aim out to justify your life.
It's like,
well,
the problem with the hierarchy is that what maybe other people will attain more
than you and you get bitter and resentful.
It's like,
well,
there's a way around that and this maybe this is a way around resentment,
which is a very,
very,
very toxic emotion.
It's like,
you know,
if you want,
we all send,
there's going to be people Richard than you and you're going to be annoyed about
that.
And if you want fame,
the same thing applies.
And then track if there's any unit dimensional system of values is going to put
you in a position where you're likely inferior.
You know?
And even if you manage to Max out on one dimension,
maybe you're wealthy of it,
you're still old and fat and bald.
It's like good luck fixing that with your wealth.
You know,
you might be a little nip and tuck will help but still isn't going to make you
younger.
So you're stuck with,
the problem with erecting the hierarchy is it produces the potential for
resentment,
but you need the hierarchy.
It's like,
well,
so how do you deal with that?
It's like,
well
maybe you're not supposed to be comparing yourself to other people and there's
real reason not to,
you know,
there really is.
Maybe when you're 60 you can compare yourself to other 16 year olds,
you know,
but by the time you're like 30 you might as well just give it up.
Because you're a strange,
when you're 30 you're like you're this thing that no one else is really like
every other 30 year old is like that tailored.
So like what are you doing comparing yourself to those other people because
they're really not light to you.
And then,
I mean it did.
I didn't notice this 30 is when it really seems to kick in because he gives so
particular in your genetics,
your biology,
your history,
your education,
your proclivities,
your experience,
all of that,
it makes you a very unique thing and multidimensionally unique thing.
How the hell are you going to compare that to someone else?
Pick one dimension and then fall short.
Well that's not very bright.
Like it's just fluff.
Seriously.
It's not a very sophisticated cognitive act,
but you need,
you still need to see that there's a better and you need to strive towards it.
So you can always use yourself as the hallmark.
It's like you kind of have some sense as these are,
as we've already discussed about how useless and worthless you fundamentally
are.
You can use that as the hallmark.
It's like it is possible to and what do this in my,
my behavior therapy practice all the time,
it's like you can probably make tomorrow like one 10th of maybe 100th of a
percent better than today.
You could probably do that.
There's some thing you could do,
minor thing and I mean you should aim low.
You really should because then you're likely to do it.
There's something you could aim at that's kind of low that you probably do that
would make your life a tiny bit better and so you'd be a better version of
yourself.
But what's so cool about that is that you don't have to do that for very long
before you get,
you start hitting the exponential gains.
That's part of that inequality distribution.
You know,
there's this idea inequalities.
The funny thing,
we talked about it already that you know,
a tiny percentage of people tend to take everything in every game.
It doesn't matter what the game is,
by the way,
it happens in pretty much every game.
But the way that that starts happening to you is by making incremental
improvements.
Cause if you're a little better tomorrow than you are today,
then the probability that you'll be able to be even a little bit better the day
after that has increased rather than decreasing because we as you are right now,
you able to make yourself a little stronger.
Also,
let's say you do that,
let's say,
and you can try this as an experiment.
This really works.
He can say,
okay,
well every day for the next year I'm going to try and make one thing slightly
better and it has to be,
you gotta be humble about this cause like you're useless.
You're not going to go to the gym three times a week.
Frankly.
You're not going to stop eating like bought bonds.
You've tried that a hundred times that you've always failed,
so a lower,
a lower aim so low that there's a good probability that you'll do it,
which is what you do if you're encouraging a child,
right?
You said you try to pick a target that,
not that it's so easy that it's contemptible because what good is that but
difficult enough to make a difference but likely enough so that you'll do it.
That's what a good behavioral psychologist does.
It's like try that,
try that for a year.
I'm just going to take myself as a baseline and I'm going to look at things that
I could improve,
that I would improve and then I'm going to do the small things.
And so that's where humility comes into it too.
Because the cap be grandiose things they might not even be something you'd ever
talked to anyone else about cause they're so trivial.
But something that you do every day is not trivial.
Something you repeat,
that's your life,
right?
Things you do every day,
that's your life.
And so if you,
if you institute that program,
take,
okay,
well just how far could I get if I did that for a year,
find out,
hey,
I'll do it for a month and see how far you could get.
You know,
and I've got 50,000 letters since August,
something like that.
From this viewer account.
I haven't,
obviously,
I'm not reading them all cause I can't,
I put my father on it,
so he's like swan
with email,
you know?
Yeah.
He hates it and loves it at the same time.
You know,
it's really quite interesting having these letters and they kind of fall into
three bs.
One Band is one person in a hundred who isn't very happy with me.
It's like,
okay,
so fine.
And then about 25% say,
and this is what my students have told me for years,
they say,
look,
listening to you has allowed me to put in words things I already knew,
but that I didn't know how to say
be good for something
hypothetically done.
It could be good for that.
So despite the older other's sins,
so,
and then the other one say I was in a bad place,
you know,
I was drinking too much or I was addicted.
I didn't get along with my family.
I was able to sit with my girlfriend and my was nihilistic,
uh,
depressed,
overweight,
didn't have a plan.
You know,
you know the horrible pitfalls pits that people can fall in.
You know there's like 30 dimensional pit of hell that people end up in.
So they ranked say how they were located in their particular bit of hail and
then say,
well look,
I've been trying to do some of the things you suggested.
You know,
whatever that is,
be more responsible or try not to lie.
That's a good thing.
Try not to lie for a month.
It's really hard.
It's almost everything you say is a lie.
It's unbelievable.
It's a good sign.
Believable.
It's how much,
it's just how lightning,
not merely that it's an outright lie.
Do you know what it to be a faucet,
but that you're saying things that have no bearing on your life.
Like they're not your things.
You know you're saying that to impress people or,
or you're saying that because you think they sound good or who knows what a bit
stuck in your mind or you read a book and you think those are your ideas now or
something like that.
All lies.
That's so you can just stop doing that and I will straighten out your horrible
to stop doing that because you find out that almost everything you say is a lie.
And that's so depressing to realize that,
you know,
the people say,
well,
you know,
I've been making incremental improvements.
I don't work.
It's so,
so fun.
This is one of the things that's so fun about what I'm doing.
What I'm doing is completely insane.
And there's lots of,
if it isn't fun at all but does some of it,
it's just great,
you know,
because wherever I go now,
people come up to me on the street and they say,
here's the little,
you know,
place in Halo than I was two years ago.
And then they describe it and they say,
look,
can I be trying out some of the things you've been recommending?
And it's way better.
It's like,
Oh God,
that's so good.
You know,
it's,
and so well that justifies the whole office as far as I'm concerned.
But,
but that's,
it's a testament to the strength of just exactly doing that.
Cause you can use yourself as your own marker.
You know perfectly well that there's more to you than meets the eye.
You absolutely know that.
That's so cool that everyone knows that.
Right?
And that's what we have,
this deep shame,
that sort of associated with original sin.
That's how the Catholics put their finger on it.
We all have this deep shame because we know who we're not who we could be.
It's like,
okay,
that's an optimistic thing.
It's like you're not who you could be.
All right,
who could you me?
Well,
maybe you could be.
It's way better than you are and who knows what that would do and why not find
out?
Because like you don't have anything better to do,
so might as well find out.
So that's an optimistic message in the middle of all the pessimism.
Rule Five,
don't let your children do anything that makes you dislike the,
I thought that
for me the most,
I thought that would be the most contentious chapter because it has to do with
disciplining children,
which is,
you know,
that's a touchy subject,
but there's two elements to that rule.
Basically you want is,
it's an,
it's an injunction to clearheaded pessimistic thinking,
I would say is the first thing you have to do if you're going to abide by that
rule is you have to admit that your children can do things that are dislikable.
No one.
Everyone knows that obviously.
I mean,
when you were a kid there were kids who hate it,
right?
It's like,
so how was that change?
And you know,
your,
your friends have kids,
you don't like them.
Some of them you don't like in this cancer,
horrible little monsters and their parents let them do it's true.
And their parents let them do all sorts of reprehensible things that are
absolutely in no one's best interest.
And they kind of either kind of embarrassed about it,
but in the sort of smiling way and they won't do anything about it.
Except then you don't invite them over anymore.
And think wider walls,
you know,
not my friends liked me ever since I have kids.
It's,
no,
it's not that.
It's your kids,
their kids,
your kids,
my kids.
And so you have to admit that kids can be dislikable.
Well that's hard tax.
And he saved the hat cause they don't,
kids are,
oh they're wonderful.
It's like,
well they are,
but we don't have to be stupidly naive about it.
So maybe you have to admit it's even worse that your kids could be dislikable.
That's a lot harder thing to swallow.
And then you have to also admit you're the sort of person that could dislike
your own kids.
And if you don't think that in your,
you're dangerous,
you're dangerous.
If you don't know that,
that's one thing you definitely learn as a clinical psychologist is because like
half the people that you see come to see you because their parents brutalized in
every possible way.
Sometimes physically,
sometimes sexually,
more often mentally.
You know,
I've had clients who like the parental rule was wait till your kid does
something good and then hit the,
you know what?
Maybe physically that's not even so bad.
I mean it's bad,
but that's not the best way to really go after someone if they're doing
something good,
you know,
you want to wait until they do something good and then maybe you want to demean
them.
You don't like with a few cutting remarks over like an hour,
something like that and [inaudible] you there are two or 300 times to your kid
and they'll be very,
very careful about ever doing anything good around you again.
You know,
then you win,
right?
Because well then you get to be martyr or a parent who has this terrible child
that you have to lug around and he was always ungrateful.
You can whine to your relatives about it and they can pat you on the back for
being so compassionate and tolerant.
This is just absolutely sickening and it happens way more often than you think
and so,
and if you don't think that you can do that,
if you don't think that you can do that,
then you don't know anything about yourself or about other human beings because
you bloody well can do that.
And the probability that you've done some of that is virtually 100% some of you
know what you need to know if you're a parent and just if you're a human being
that you are a sub type of monster and you should be very careful with how you
act.
And part of that is you should be very careful with your children.
Like I knew why didn't talk,
I had kids,
I kind of knew what I was like,
although not as much as I might've,
but I knew something about what it was like and I thought,
I'm not going to let my kids make me upset and angry because God only knows what
will happen if they do that.
And it isn't like an explosive outburst of tamper or something like that.
You know?
You hear now and then about a parent who's done something absolutely dreadful to
their children and you think,
well,
how could that happen?
It's just think about it for awhile.
If you actually want to know how something like that could happen,
you just have to sit and think about it for about an hour.
Like it's horrifying to put yourself in the place of that parent.
People generally won't do it,
but if you want to understand,
you can,
you can understand.
It's just that you said you don't want to and no wonder,
but I knew that I was perfectly capable of taking revenge on anybody that
crossed me,
let's say,
and that the best way to deal without,
apart from trying to improve my own character,
listening to my wife when she's trying to,
you know,
sort me out,
was to not encourage my children to be horrible little monsters because they're
little and fragile and I'm way bigger and way meaner and way more malevolent.
And so it's much better for them.
It's much better for them if they behave in a manner that elicits the positive
element from me.
And it's not that hard to encourage children to do that.
Like if you have some sense and you'd notice your own irritation,
I mean you can't assume your perfect because you're not and you're going to have
arbitrary irritations,
but that's partly why you have a partner to kind of keep you on the straight and
narrow,
but you do your children a great favor by not letting them act in a way that
irritates you.
But even more importantly,
and this is where the rubber really hits the road,
is what's your role as a parent to promote the self esteem of your children?
It's like,
no,
no.
That is not your role.
That's bald headed
psychologists.
[inaudible]
your role is to make your children welcome wherever they go.
That's your role.
Your role is to help your children maintain that gloss of innocence and
attracted this.
That's part and parcel of being a child so that when they interact with other
children,
those children want to play it with them.
If that means your child has to know how to play.
Super important that your child knows how to play with other kids because other
kids socialize your children.
And if your child isn't socialized properly by the age of four so that other
children want to play with him or her,
they're done.
You failed and you can't fix it.
So it's really because what happens is the kids play with the other kids who can
play and their development takes off and you're a kid who can't play,
gets left in the dust.
And there's a huge literature on that,
that very,
very depressing literature,
like most truthful psychological literatures.
And that's what it indicates.
And so,
well it's the case,
you know,
if you're a social scientist,
you know you've discovered something true.
If you hate it and it violates your political instincts,
it's like a fact
[inaudible] so,
but you also want for your children,
like we taught our kids how to behave in restaurants.
We,
we take them to restaurants when they were little all in for about 45 minutes
when they were little.
Cause you can't expect a kid to sit for too long,
but you know the rule,
it was,
well you can come to the restaurant but you have to act like a civilized
creature and if you didn't then we went and stood outside.
You know,
and even if it was winter,
so I could remember my daughter who's in the audience tonight,
by the way,
Stephanie [inaudible],
please behave in the restaurant.
Judge Tall,
some stunting cause kids will do that and you take them to a new place.
They'll pull some stuff.
They never try it at home.
It's because they know and they think,
ha,
what are you going to do if I do this here?
It's like I'm going to take you on.
Sorry,
we're going to stamp where it's cold down there.
She looked at me and I look at her say,
how's this going for you?
It's like,
it's like,
yeah.
It's cool though here.
Race like was it better than the restaurant?
Yeah,
it was.
Do you want to go back to the restaurant?
Yeah.
You want to act like a civilized human being and we'll go back at the
restaurant.
It's like,
yeah,
okay back.
We'd go.
I know it was pretty straight forward.
It's pretty straight forward,
you know,
so and that worked.
But what was so fun about that was first of all we got to go to restaurants and
so that lead is not quite as bitter and horrible about being parents as we
might've been.
The second was,
you know that adults are there adults,
he didn't know the kids would respond to them really positively.
So we take the kids to restaurants and they'd all sit there and smile and eaten,
you know,
be civilized in that other parents or other adults will come along and say they
pat them and say,
you know,
you kids really behaved well and then they'd actually smile at them.
You know how it fits a kid into restaurant causing all sorts of trouble.
You kind of smile.
But like a carnivorous Fab pyre.
That's sorta how you smile.
But the kids would go out and because they were behaving,
you know,
with a certain amount of propriety that all the adults would show their good
side.
Cause I don't actually like kids,
you know like you have to be a pretty dark person to not have a small child
light,
a little light in your heart,
you know?
And so as long as the child isn't doing everything in its power to extinguish
that light,
then you know,
you can get some positive responses even from really rough people.
And so the kids would go out to restaurants and people would pat them and smile
at them and not like how,
why would you want that for your kids?
You want your kids,
other kids like them.
What a deal.
Then other kids liked them and invite them to play games and they have a good
life and adults want to have them around and we'll be nice to them and teach
them things.
It's like your dad parent,
you're done right.
And you can do most of that by the time the kids for so,
but you have to come to the terms with the fact that kids aren't innately good
and neither are you.
That's for sure.
And so you have to act like a,
like a intelligent person with some,
some apprehension of your own horror and the terrible things that you're capable
of doing and then regulate your household so that those things aren't necessary.
And so that's really useful.
So that's rule five.
Well
rule six,
put yourself house in perfect order before you criticize the world.
So
[inaudible]
about the mass shooters mostly not only I talk about this guy named Carl,
Pam's round in the chapter and pans ramp was this mass killer.
He kept track of everyone he killed.
He kept track of all the buildings he first down and the dollar value.
He was out for mayhem and no wonder like he was a delinquent kid.
I think he was one kid at 14 or something in the Midwest and he's kind of a bad
kid.
And then they sent them to a reform school as they did not help put it that way.
He was seriously brutalized in the reform school in all the inventive and
creative ways that you might imagine that a child could be abused in a reform
school.
That basically happened to him.
And when he came out,
he was not a happy person.
And so he decided that he would devote his life to producing as much misery as
he possibly could.
And he wrote it.
He wrote an autobiography.
He was in prison,
beat half to death by the guards and no doubt deservedly so.
And uh,
a doctor in the prison gave him a dollar to buy cigarettes or something like
that,
pads around in his own accounts had that,
that was the only kind of thing that he could remember anyone ever doing for
them.
Well then,
no wonder,
I mean,
you know,
it's a complicated story,
but he wasn't like,
he was like a dog that comes up to you and bites your ankle and is surprised
that it doesn't get petted,
you know.
So,
and I'm saying that with some due regard for the fact that he did in fact have
an absolutely dismal life.
Right?
I mean,
he got tortured pretty bad that he was very badly when he was a teenager.
Um,
anyways,
Patra writes about his hatred for,
it's not just himself,
but for other people,
absolute hatred.
But it went way past that because like if you're going to hate,
you're only get warmed up if you hate yourself and other people that's you
think,
well that's about as bad as it can get.
It's like,
no,
like there's this old idea that hell is a bottomless pit,
you know,
and there's a psychological reason for that.
And the reason for that is,
is that no matter how bad something is,
you could make it worse.
And so like there's no limit to hate.
And you might start by hating yourself and other people,
but that's your,
that's just beginner hate.
If you really push it,
not only do you come to hate,
you would come to hate being itself.
The mere fact that the reason anything fills you with rage,
but that isn't even where you,
you don't even stop there if you're really proficient at he,
ew,
ew.
That's of a philosophical hate and you're getting pretty down to the bottom of
things when you're philosophical in your hatred,
but you're not as far down as you could get if you want to get right to the
bottom and you get theological into your hate,
and if you get,
feel logical in your hate,
and I don't care if you're at the ECS than your pull the page,
it doesn't make any difference.
It's this is this.
That's all irrelevant.
You Act as if there's someone responsible for the horror of being,
let's
call that God and you hate him
and then you do everything you possibly can to make that be a hypothetical or
otherwise as angry and sad about your existence,
antibiotic resistance itself as you possibly can with all of the imagination and
tools at your disposal and then you,
you,
you're getting way down in the Haight hierarchy when you do that,
and if you don't believe that,
go read about it.
Go read the diaries of the kids who shot up the Columbine high school and see if
that isn't exactly what they say.
These people,
you know,
they write manifestos,
they tell you exactly what they're thinking and that's exactly what they tell
you and that's what pans up his head.
He said,
you know what his dying words are.
I wish the human race pet one neck so that I could put my hands around it.
Then squeeze.
That's one of the quotes.
That's a pretty good one.
His dying words,
he was being hung.
There was a woman's group that tried to stop him from being hung and he wasn't
very happy with him by the way.
And let them know that quite blunt blade.
And he said he was in Indiana.
He said to the hang man,
hurry up you,
who's your basket?
I could kill tip men and the time it's taking you to new stuff.
No.
Right.
That's Carl pants route man.
That's really something.
So the chapters about him and it's about the Columbine kids who left a pretty
decent stock of writings.
And how about the guy who showed up the elementary school about people like
that,
if what their motivation is and why they're so angry,
like so unbelievably hellishly say tactically angry cause that's the only
language that really suffices to describe that level of outreach.
You can't even,
you're not even close to describing what's going on in situations like that.
You find yourself forced to use a theological language.
It's the only language that suffices to encapsulate that kind of absolute
brutality.
It's,
it's,
it's hellish.
Okay.
They make a powerful case for him.
Yeah.
That's the thing.
It's powerful enough to convince them of it's right now.
Sorry,
I looked at that.
All right.
It's all about it.
A lot.
Almost like cause life is very hard and people do get betrayed in there is
malevolence in the world.
Like it's,
yeah,
the,
I don't think there's a single person alive who doesn't have some point think,
okay,
well maybe I should it that's one thing.
But not even that to say,
well maybe this is just so terrible that it should just not exist at all.
You'll find yourself in situations like that when your dreams are dashed really
in an unpleasant way or someone close to you has a very,
very painful illness,
something like that.
Especially if it's a child,
it's very easy to B two B.
Well,
to find yourself questioning whether beating itself is a justifiable,
if reality itself is just the firewall.
It's like because of all it's suffering.
So what do you do about,
so there's this book I read called the cocktail party Celia,
and then in the cocktail party there's a woman who speaks to a psychiatrist and
she says that her life isn't going very well.
She's suffering a lot,
and she tells the psychiatrist,
I really hope that this is my fault.
I'm the psychiatrist says,
well,
what do you mean you hope?
If this is your fault,
why would you hope that?
And she says,
well,
look,
if it's my fault,
then maybe I could do something about it.
But if it's just,
this is just how it is,
it's like if this is just the structure of reality,
then I've lost.
You know,
that's a really good thought.
Well,
Tsla Ian was a genius.
That's a really good thoughts,
like that's a pretty good place to start because you think,
well,
when everything isn't going you away and that's going to happen a lot.
You know when,
when there's suffering,
the suffering in your life exceeds what you think to be reasonable and you
attempted to curse fate with all that.
That entails.
You think,
well,
have you done everything that you could do?
Have you put your house in order?
There's opportunities that are sitting there in front of you.
It's like,
have you made full use of the right?
Have you imagined?
Because life is so difficult that you don't get to waste.
You don't get to waste it.
You don't get to waste resources.
They're too precious because you have too big a problem to solve and why waste
resources so things aren't turning out for you exactly the way you want them to.
It's like,
well,
how much time are you wasting?
All right.
You Ask my students there 20 something years old at the crowd of the maybe 200 I
say,
okay,
let's,
let's do a quick analysis of your life.
How many of you wasted an hour a day?
It's like everybody puts up their hands three hours a day.
Everybody puts up their hands.
It's like usually by seven hours a day.
Some people have their hands down,
right?
I just wasted time.
Like man,
we do a quick financial analysis cause like if you're a university student,
maybe your time's worth 50 bucks an hour or something like that.
If you consider in terms of,
you know,
lifetime earnings,
it's like seven hours a,
it's $350
a day.
It's about $2,000 a week,
$40,000 months for $100,000 a year.
It's like,
fine.
It's like your life isn't everything.
It could be you're wasting a hundred thousand dollars worth of your time a year.
It's like maybe possibly there's a causal connection.
It's worth contemplating,
right?
Kind of.
This is an existential question.
It's like,
and I don't know the answer to this because I do know that life is brutally
difficult and that we're up against it all the time,
both in terms of tragedy and malevolence.
It's no joke,
man,
it's,
it's full frontal attack.
If you're a human being,
it's like what do you have to mitigate against that?
And that's sort that is you have what presents itself to you as possibility and
opportunity.
That's all you have.
And so then you might say,
well,
if you made full use of everything that was offered to you,
what would your life be like?
And that's,
that's a thought that you can use productively.
It pretty much every situation forever.
And there's something about it that's really like,
it's a really profound idea because it is the case that you have.
I actually think this is the case.
I think that what we confront,
this is how I think reality is constituted.
I think that we confront reality as divine centers of consciousness.
I don't,
I don't think there's a better way of saying that.
And the reason I say that define is because we don't understand consciousness at
all.
We don't understand its relationship to material reality.
And we do know that it's intake really involved with being no consciousness,
no,
no one to experience what is there.
Well,
you can't even say there's a,
we've confront potential consciously,
we interact with it.
Well,
how much potential is there?
we're a very finite and constrained like a genie in a,
it allows just like that.
That's where that idea exists.
We're constrained,
you know,
and,
and there's reason for that.
It's a complicated reason,
but we won't go into that for a moment.
But,
but what we confront seems to be something that's essentially infinite in its
potential.
So then you take,
well,
if you have an impossible problem and you do,
you have an impossible problem.
And so does everybody else.
What do you need to solve an impossible problem?
You need an infinite,
you need it for the potential to solve an impossible problem.
Well,
maybe you have that right in front of you.
And I actually think this is true.
I think that if you conducted your life as if what you had in front of you was
infinite potential,
that he find out that that was true.
And I think that in interacting with that,
you'd also find what you needed to justify the catastrophe of your life.
That that's what you need to do.
And maybe maybe you could even find it so that you would accept it.
You'd except the,
because
I tried to develop this too in the rest of the book and I didn't think I'll
probably close with this.
I thought about my son when he was a little kid.
You know,
it's about three.
He was super cute kid.
I still think he's cute,
but he's like 26 and he doesn't care.
So He's a really cute kid.
But you know,
he's three and three year olds.
They're like,
they stand up under tables and bumped their head.
Like they fall down the stairs and other kids pushed them over.
It's like,
you know,
you're pretty fragile when you're three and it's kind of painful if you're a
parrot noticing how fragile and your children are.
And so you think,
well,
it's painful that fragility.
And then so I did a little thought exercise.
I thought,
okay,
well let's,
let's dispense with the fragility since it's so painful.
It's like,
well he shouldn't be like three feet tall because that's not working out 20 feet
tall.
That'd be good.
And then,
well,
why camper to be made of flesh and blood?
Because what we do,
we know if that that's a problem.
It's like to,
how about titanium?
Who just replace it with robotic part so it can be 20 feet tall and made of
titanium.
It don't want,
obviously you want something like that to be capable of defending itself.
So it's kind of a fighting machine.
It's like,
okay,
well so now I can dispense with my three year old sound and I can have this 20
foot tall robotic fighting machine that's more or less indestructible.
It's like,
who's going to make that trade?
And that's strange j because it's not,
it's not obvious why you wouldn't make that trade.
But what happens is that by sacrificing that for agility,
which is what you'd be doing,
you actually end up sacrificing what you love.
And so then you think,
well,
isn't that a funny thing?
Because we,
we love people.
You know,
we all have someone we love if we're,
if we're the least bit fortunate and so often our children hopefully,
but then there's that,
but it's,
you see this also when your parents get older,
you know,
they start getting fragile and all sorts of ways and you think,
well God,
it's not so good that there so fragile.
It's like,
okay,
start replacing it.
What were you going to stop?
You're going to start with all of that fragility gone.
It's like the person's gone then.
And so then there's this strange way where if you love someone,
you civil tenuously love and accept their fragility and that,
that means that in some way you actually think it's justifiable that the heart,
that's what I thought about my son.
It's like,
no,
I think he's fine.
Just the way he is like three years old,
God has problems,
you know,
certainly gets hurt a fair bit.
And is probably going to get hurt more,
but I'm not trained in.
I liked them just the way he is.
And so that's like a,
it's a realization of the soul that there's something about the fragility of
human life that's actually valuable and they just still limitation.
That's the thing that's so cool about it is that it's this limitation that we
are because that's what we are,
is we're limitation.
We're,
we're,
we're potential.
Can conjoin with limitation in some sense take well we want to get rid of the
limitation but it's not the case.
We have to keep the limitation because it's integral to who we are.
And so we're in this situation where we have to be limited and we have to accept
it and we have to confront what's essentially an infinite potential to help us
manage it.
And I think that,
I think that that's why I think that that's true.
I think that's how we act.
I think it's what we expect.
I think it's what we need to know cause you have to say,
and that's part of standing up straight paid and accepting the tragedy and
catastrophe of existence.
This is partly why I think the West Florida,
right?
Because I do think we got it right.
The central story where a Judeo Christian culture and there's a,
there's a central story at the bottom and the story is about the radical
acceptance of fragility.
That's what the crucifixion represents.
The fact that that's a voluntary act and it,
it's about everybody.
That's the thing.
It's about everybody.
It's that,
well,
you're going to die,
you're going to be betrayed.
Those are going to happen.
And so you can either shrink from that and maybe,
and maybe it develop yourself in bitterness and hatred and no wonder no other,
or you can say,
bring it on,
bring it on.
[inaudible]
and so I would say,
well,
I've looked at dark things as much as I can,
you know,
and I think that's probably hurt me in many ways,
but let's be not unbelievably helpful,
you know,
because the thing about darkness is it makes the light stand up.
And as I've looked deeper and deeper into terrible things,
I've also realized that that there's something amazing about human beings.
You know,
because we are,
our lives are bounded by tragedy and we are capable of deep malevolence more
solar than you can almost imagine,
but I don't think that's what defines us.
I really don't.
I think what defines us is the ability to transcend that.
I truly believe that and so I'm not pessimistic.
I'm optimistic and knowing know.
I do believe that people,
I believe that people are embodied miracles.
I really think that's the right way of thinking about it and I think we all know
this and what I'm hoping egg in these polarized times is that
that we return to that realization and that we adopt the responsibility of full
individual.
Big has an antidote to well idiot political polarization,
but also as an impetus for us all to move forward into the future.
We're in an inflection point.
I think in our culture,
in the world,
things are opening up in front of us that have never opened up before and it's
very dangerous.
Our technological prowess is very dangerous and things could go very dreadfully
wrong,
but I don't think they have to.
I think they could go extraordinarily.
Right.
And I think that each of us,
I do believe this,
that every single person sitting here,
every single person there is,
but every single person sitting here plays a key role in that decision.
No,
we're all part of it.
We're deeply networked.
We all influence everyone else.
And we are these divine centers of consciousness that are separate but United at
the same time.
And the decisions that each of us make as individuals are far more important
than we realize our lives are ultimately it meaningful I think.
And that we do decide whether by our actions we're going to bring a worse or a
better cosmos into Ba.
And I would say that we should dispense with our resentment and bitterness
despite the fact that we have every reason for it and stand up and face things
forthrightly and speak the truth and make the world a better place.
[inaudible]
and that seems like a good place to stop.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
am I mistaken or he only knocked out six rules there.
Huh?
You guys want to do this at my place after?
Okay.
I look that could quite get all yet,
but we'll try it.
We'll see what we can do.
All right Jordan,
just taking a second to just happen to have the glass of water and uh,
maybe loosen his tie and then,
uh,
I mean,
I guess we can do a Q and a unless you guys fully got all that.
All right.
[inaudible]
oh,
Harry is Jordan Peterson.
[inaudible]
all right.
So I said is we're going to have roughly 40 billion questions.
There's two mics on the sides down here.
They couldn't do it for logistical reasons upstairs,
but we're told we will call on one or two.
You guys have yet,
if you speak clearly,
but why don't we start,
are we over here?
Where am I low?
And looking right over here,
you try to keep it kind of brief and a no major or Asian so we can get to as
many questions as possible.
Take it away.
Good evening.
Uh,
my question is for Dr. Peterson.
You referenced in 12 rules and thank you for your time.
Your referencing should follow the rules to the dragon that gets bigger and
small increments if leftover,
if ignored.
Um,
I was wondering if you thought that it was possible to assume that you have
certain groups on the left,
if they achieve what they felt maybe was equity,
could that possibly lead to them wanting to then go further and actually subject
their political enemies?
Like what was no problem with the equity idea is that there's no limit to the
number of fractionation is you can make,
you can generate for group identity.
So there's an unlimited number of dimensions across which equity might be
attained.
Problem number one.
Problem number two is there's an infinite fractionation of group identity.
So it's a problem.
It can never be sold.
So I mean what,
what groups are you going to make equal?
Cause that's a quick followup.
I guess what,
so just one step further would need them.
So if they achieve some type of equity,
would they maybe determined that they're not going to be happy until they're in
charge of other people?
Well,
well that,
that question means what?
What's the motivation at the bottom of all this?
And I don't believe that the motivation is equity at all.
Like I think the motivation is the ending of the patriarchal tyranny,
and it will find the mentally,
and that's not the same.
Those are just mechanisms.
Like having said that,
look,
I already stated that inequality is a problem.
Inequality drives the left and fair enough.
Like that's where you need a left wing is because inequality is actually a
political problem.
But the radical abolishment of inequality is not a possible goal.
There's one thing I did want to say.
We actually have a technical problem in our culture.
Okay.
And it's something that's worth thinking about.
So the technical problem is we can draw a border around the radical,
right.
You know,
so conservatives can say,
okay,
here's some people to the right of me and they're claiming racial superiority
doctrines.
Let's say,
okay,
we're gonna put them in a box and we're going to say,
you're not us and we're not playing that game.
Okay.
Right,
right.
And that that happened with William F.
Buckley back in the 60s when,
when he started his conservative movement and disassociated themselves from the
white supremacists.
So like,
okay,
now we know that people can go too far on the right,
right?
That was what the Nazis for there,
but then we know that people can go too far on the left.
It was a beat.
The communists and 100 million people they manage to kill.
Okay,
so we know that people can go too far on the left.
what's the marker?
Okay.
And the answer is we don't know.
And that's not a good enough answer,
especially not for people on the list,
because they have the same ethical responsibility to dissociate themselves from
the dangerous radicals.
Has the Conservatives do on the right,
but they're incapable of doing it.
Now,
partly it's technical.
It's like,
well,
you can point to racial superiority doctrines on the right can.
You can say,
no,
we're not going there.
What exactly do you 0.2 on the left?
Because the idea is in,
in their individual form,
see,
well at least harmless.
Even though they're not,
they seem at least harvest and they ha they have the mask of even something that
appears to be beneficial.
Now I think of all the pathological ideas on the left,
the most dangerous is equity.
I would say when people start talking about equality of outcome,
they've crossed the Rubicon and then it's incumbent on reasonable people in the
center and on the left can point that out and dissociate themselves from them
and they're not doing it and it's not good.
Thank you.
If only there was someone that came from the left that had been trying to do
that,
but his past couple of years,
Ruben.
All right to say I gave up three hours of gameplay play.
Okay,
and it's questions about Zelda.
No.
Here's an interesting spin off from the Jq that I've been pondering on recently.
How do we solve nepotism and [inaudible] preferences in groups as the majority
of the power and influence?
Is it even a problem at all?
By the way,
this doesn't have to do anything with Rice.
Any differential factor can,
yeah,
it can be used here.
Well,
I mean I think that we solved the problem with nepotism.
The way that we have essentially solved it in the west.
You know,
our bureaucracies for example,
are basically meritocratic.
No,
you know,
measuring merit is no simple thing,
right?
Because it's not easy to establish a measurement that actually has a decent
correlation with the desired outcome.
If it was easy,
everybody could set up a successful business,
it's actually very difficult.
But we have decided,
imagine that managing your institution has a function.
Okay.
Which you know is not so difficult to imagine.
And then imagine people differ in that function,
which obviously they will then imagine,
imagine you could measure those differences.
Now we kind of do that.
So for example,
if you're applying to university,
you might have to take the sat because we know that sat scores roughly sample
the same competence domain that university does now.
It's not perfect by any stretch.
In fact,
the correlation between her sat scores and grades is about 0.4 or something like
that.
So leaves about 85% 70% let's say of the variance unexplained,
but it's on [inaudible],
active and neutral and it's the best that we've got.
And so that's what you do is you reduce people,
the individuals first of all and then you say,
well,
we're going to assist you in accordance with your competence in relationship to
the function of this organization had.
That's all we're going to do.
We do that quite well now it's,
it's very difficult if we can't do it perfectly,
but there isn't a better solution and to to substitute instead like quotas for
race and sex is,
well it's impossibly dangerous.
It promotes us into the identity politics realm and that's subject gates,
the individual to the group and that's fine if you want like on travel
tribalism,
okay,
go for it.
But we know where as elite it leads to,
it leads to death.
That's where it leads and maybe that's what you want.
Why don't we try one one up in the second?
Anyone over there,
right there.
Yes,
yes.
Can you talk to any,
is there any benefits or the negative emotion in your role or is it just let me
someone else.
Okay,
so then the question is the gentleman,
who else the question said he took my personality test and scored rather high in
neuroticism and asked if there was any benefit to that.
Well,
you know,
the answer is,
the answer is it's a normal distribution,
right?
And so sometimes if you're terrified out of your skull and hiding in the
basement,
then the king's tyrants don't cut off your head.
Right.
So there are times when the environment is so dangerous that you should be
terrified all the time and high.
Like lots of human environments are like that.
Right.
You know,
in,
in many,
you know,
in,
in a western culture you might think,
well,
extroverted and emotionally stable is a pretty good solution.
Fair bit of positive emotion,
fair bit of verbal assertiveness nor too much fear.
It's like,
well,
if you were like an extroverted,
extroverted and emotionally stable in 1930s in the Soviet Union,
you were like,
damn,
fuck.
Yeah.
Because like if you're introverted and terrified,
then maybe you will be killed.
So it's brutal because you have to put up with the neuroticism,
right?
You have to put up with the anxiety and maybe with the volatility as well.
But in a hyper dangerous environment,
it's inappropriate strategy.
So now having said that,
I would also say that if you're neuroticism levels are extremely elevated,
then there's some possibility that you have an anxiety disorder or that you're
depressed or that there's something wrong with you physically that you might
want to get checked out.
So because there's lots of reasons to be upset and unhappy and some of them are
temperamental,
you know,
that's just how you're wired.
And you can detect that in kids as early as six months.
But sometimes it's a secondary consequence of you know,
other things that have happened in your life or,
or,
or general ill health.
So I also think I've been puzzling for a long time over why women have higher
levels of negative emotion than men.
And I think,
I think there's a couple of reasons for it.
It kicks in at puberty,
by the way,
because it isn't true for boys and girls,
but it is true for adult men and women and it's true throughout the lifespan.
I think the reason for it is is that the world's actually more objectively
dangerous to women at an individual level,
partly because they're sexually vulnerable and also partly because they're
physically smaller,
so it makes sense that they'd be more nervous,
but then also I think women are more sensitive to negative emotion because they
have to be sensitive to the distress of India of infants because it isn't
obvious to me at all that female nervous systems are adapted for the individual
female.
I think they're probably adapted for the infant mother dyad and you're a lot
more vulnerable as an infant mother diet than you are as an individual.
But I mean you have to be,
you know,
if you're a good mother,
especially of really young infants,
you know when your infant is sleeping and wakes up,
goes beep,
you're a right response is to jump out of bed awake and alert and go likely
nurse the infant and you have to be on a hair trigger essentially to be that
sensitive.
Well you pay a price.
Like if you think about it,
you pay a price for being sensitive to your infant.
Why the hell wouldn't you pay a price for that?
Cause it's really like infants are a lot of work.
They require a lot of care.
You have to be super attentive to them.
They're unbelievably dependent.
And so to be wired for that means you're going to pay a price.
Like maybe it's going to be harder for you to deal with adult males because
you're more sensitive to the distress of infants.
Highly probable.
So these things are
okay.
You'd never get an advantage without paying a price.
That's,
that's basically the rule from a temperamental perspective
right here.
Adoptive Peterson.
My name's John Carlo,
Patelco.
First.
I just want to thank you so much for sharing the fruits of your suffering with
us and all of the work that you've done.
I love it.
Appreciate it.
Thank you for doing that.
Sharing.
I guess my question is about technology.
I've been doing a lot of thinking about the role of technology in our evolution.
It's cert an amazing purpose in creating distance between us nature so that we
can survive and live longer.
Um,
but it seems like we've reached a point of which technology is so deeply
embedded in our lives that it is preventing us from living a more meaningful by,
and I'm thinking specifically of the fact that we now have these mobile devices
that are with us,
except when we were in the shower and when we're sleeping basically.
And now there are water provide phones.
So I don't know what's going to happen next,
but we have these phones with us all the time and they've got social media on
that.
It seems like it kind of addictive and distracting us from ourselves and our
lives.
And it's something that I'm exploring and working on and have transformed my
life by taking control over.
I'm wondering if you have thoughts about,
uh,
the role of technology in our lives and if we've reached a turning point in some
ways.
Well,
okay,
I won't comment specifically on the cellphone.
I think the reason for that is that we're in a place where the rate of
technological transformation is so fast that the probability that cell phones
will still be the problem in 10 years is zero.
Right?
It'll be something else and maybe something even more difficult to manage.
And so,
you know,
I talked about this idea that this infinite landscape of potential is opening
itself up to us even more right now than it has in the past with his tremendous
rate of technological transformation.
Well,
the question is,
you're,
the broader question that you have is how do we deal with this?
And that's a great question.
But I would say the answer to that is prepare yourself.
You know,
because if I say,
well,
there's,
there's a bunch,
there's a lot going to come at you in the next 10 years.
And there's no predicting what it's going to be.
It's going to be something that can be used for ill and something that can be
used for good.
Well,
but we can't predict it.
So what should you do?
And the answer is you should prepare,
right?
You should eradicate your obvious weaknesses,
you should strengthen yourself,
you should become more alert and more educated and more disciplined and that,
and you'll do that in your own particular way and that will make you a better
whoever you are that you are now.
And as a collective,
that's the best we've got because,
and,
and I mean this is a really deep level.
We have become a planetary transforming force and that's probably really been
true since the end of World War II.
Right?
When we invented the hydrogen bomb,
it was like that was a,
that was a whole new thing.
And we obviously have to develop the wisdom that will enable us to manage that
because what else are we going to do otherwise we're infants with,
with guns.
And one of the things I learned from Carl,
you know what I really liked,
I really liked this,
is he was very interested in Alchemy,
which was a weird ad mixture of ethics,
religion and produce.
Science is the birthplace is science.
And it was kind of a dream and the was that human beings could investigate the
material world and generate the philosopher's stone,
which would make everybody healthy,
wealthy,
immortal.
But there was a dream.
They're,
the dream was we could discover that by investigating the material world.
And that was the impetus for the development of science.
Well,
that took off like mad.
And in some sense we have discovered the philosopher's stone.
We are much healthier,
we lived much longer,
were far richer,
and that was all a consequence of,
of,
of investigating the material world.
But there was a lot of religious and ethical thinking that was part and parcel
of the l chemical dream.
And it didn't grow the same way.
And so it's like we're stuck ethically in like 1600 and we're,
and technologically it's,
it's the 21st century and that's not good enough.
We have to become as powerful as quickly as we are scientifically or,
or we'll do ourselves in.
So that,
and I think that's part of what we're trying to sort out is what's our ethical
responsibility?
How good could we become as individuals and where could that take us if we
decide to go there?
So,
and cell phones are one small but significant element of that credibly powerful
devices,
but requiring wisdom in their management and that's just going to get worse
because there are things coming down the pipes technologically that we can,
we can't even imagine.
So thank you so much.
No,
it's the antidote.
It's the justification.
It's not a distraction.
It can't be a distraction because if it's a distraction and it just,
it won't work.
You know,
generally people distract themselves with trivialities,
you know,
with,
with cheap,
impulsive entertainment.
And I don't have anything against even cheap,
impulsive entertainment for that matter.
But it's not,
it's not something that you do well.
You're busily suffering yourself into extinction.
It's like I do believe that I,
and I believe that there's evidence for this,
that that instinct of meaning is the deepest instinct that you have and it
actually does orient you to the proper place.
Whatever that means.
It means something biological that means something political.
It means something economic.
But I think it means something universal as well because I do think that
consciousness plays a central role in being.
And so if you orient yourself towards what's meaningful,
then you participate in all those levels at the same time.
I don't know what the ultimate significance of that is,
but I suppose it's the same as the ultimate significance of reality itself.
But there's something profound too.
It's not just a distraction by any.
Like I don't think we're away.
We'll Rome burns.
I don't think you find pleasant occupations to preoccupy yourself while you,
while you trudge towards death.
You know,
it's not like that.
It's
the orientation towards meeting is a fundamental reality.
You're neurologically wired and so it's real.
Now what that means ultimately,
I don't know.
But one thing I do know that it means is that it means less hell.
And that's something,
right.
Really that's something so we could start with that and see where it goes.
Yeah,
sure.
If you stand up to it,
everybody can hear you,
right?
Yeah.
I'm going to want to university CME.
And your lack of it.
Part of the reason why I decided to make my intended major neuroscience.
Yup.
Kind of in if it's under,
I was like,
yeah.
And I was just wondering in terms of what the Canyon and psychologically works,
you know Floyd Young,
does it matter which order you read the books in or finish kind of getting
started with Rogers Rogers.
Yeah.
Rogers is a very useful thing practically.
So that's Carl Rogers,
the psychotherapist.
I'd recommend his writings.
He wrote a book called the way of being,
which is a really great book.
Gary Rogers was a very practical person and I think a good person,
but it's,
it's very clear.
Um,
Freud is harder and Yeoman.
Is it possible?
Very terrible.
Oh yeah.
You don't want to start with that.
Yeah,
no,
no.
That's advanced.
This.
That's partly why he didn't publish it.
He didn't publish.
So here's a reading list on my,
on my website.
Okay.
The best thing,
if you're interested in cycle in psychological theory,
I think the best book,
likely especially psychoanalytic theory,
is a book called the discovery of the unconscious.
And then we'll give you an introduction to Freud and Jung and Adler and also did
the history of psychoanalytic thought.
It's a brilliant book.
It's really quite any gross Greek as well.
So that's a really good place to start.
We have time for,
thank you very much.
We have time for one.
One last question.
Okay.
I'm your girl.
Who's the girl who's there?
All right.
You said recently that uh,
you'll never grow up and tell you how your own children,
yeah.
Coming from a woman who doesn't have any children but is trying to sort herself
out and has mental issues in their history,
is it,
is it more important to sort yourself out and do the best you can and try to get
to adulthood in that way?
Or is it really necessary to have kids?
You know,
this is something Carl Young said about psychotherapy.
He said that it can be replaced by a supreme moral effort because young like
most of the great knew that a lot of what d ranges people in their life is
falsehood.
You know,
Freud talked about repression and Alfred Adler talked about the lifeline and
Carl Rogers talked about,
you know,
anticipate and sort of the existential psychotherapist,
they all,
they all had their finger on the idea that just straighten yourself out as a
moral effort.
The thing about having kids that's telling is that if you have a child then it's
almost inevitable that you will then come to regard someone else as more
important than you.
And like I think you can do that.
Other ones,
there's other routes to that,
but they're hard.
I mean,
because the reason to,
anything that's a bigger commitment are there very few things that are a bigger
commitment than having a child.
And so it forces,
it catalyzes a change in you that you're entirely prepared for it.
And I think there are ways of doing that for people who don't have children,
but,
but it's,
it's tar.
That's right.
It,
it,
it requires the same sort of effort.
I wouldn't say that having a child requires,
which is a lot of effort to do so,
but I'm going to make statements like that.
They have to be,
you know,
they're,
what are they?
They're crunchy and generalized.
And it's not to say that there are no people who are mature that don't have
children,
but this fastest and most certain way to maturity for people is to have a
chocolate.
That also doesn't mean that everyone who has a child becomes mature.
So because they don't generally,
they at least become more mature than they were,
which is something
we have to abandon theater.
[inaudible].